live streaming isn't available right now
John let's face facts wait are we live I
can't really can tell if we're alive or
not I can't either what the hell's
happening
what's it says excellent connection I'm
so confused
I am as well maybe I'll refresh this
page just to see what they can hear us
you can hear it can you see us can you
see us because right now the feed on
this is very very weird right now oh
you're alive we're doing this now from
stream labs for various reasons and the
thing is usually it starts up just fine
but sometimes it'll it'll launch its
little page and immediately crash and
leave you in the sticks going I guess
we'll try it from YouTube oh I'm so so
happy you guys are here this is gonna be
a fun one today
this is gonna be so fun hello ever I see
a lot of a lot of familiar names and
here's some new names I haven't seen
before hello everyone how's everyone
doing today
so because it's 4th of July tomorrow we
were like and I'm having a huge party a
huge gathering fighting everyone if you
guys are watching I'm encouraging you to
go out there party all night long
tomorrow just go to the beaches mingle
hug with your shirts off mm-hmm if you
know me you know that I am all sincere
right now definitely go out there and
have a great time plenty of alcohol
coffin people's faces lick the windows
like I've seen people do in those viral
videos
the longer we can go with this
quarantine situation the happier of a
camper will all be yeah isn't Saturday
it's not Saturday Saturday on Friday
you put Saturday Night Live Streaming
the title accidentally jeez John I
wonder if I can edit it like that you
got to think and no yes let's clarify
I'm only joking okay I don't want to get
canceled off of I want a sarcastic
and I made but yeah I thought today
would be a fun one this is a topic
that's been requested several times and
usually I kind of just whip up some
topic the day of but this time around I
was like let's just do one that's from a
request of a lot and this once a day is
sequels we'd like to see made and and so
a gentle Randolph what's up girls Jenna
and John's John's fixing it right now so
if you guys don't want to be mad at John
yeah it's fixed it's going there refresh
the page you'll see that it says Friday
and I live stream right I'm sorry about
goddamnit
it's just so catchy you know Saturday
night lives I know that's why I wanted
to do it on Saturday yeah the point is
to confuse people into being here until
they don't realize that we are not part
of the SNL cast and also if you guys
have any Hopkins yes party with us if
you guys do super chat thank you much
appreciated if you don't feel
comfortable to totally get it and also
if you do want to contribute we also
have stream labs which is cooler because
YouTube takes like 45% whatever you yeah
it takes less fees and also gets to us
much quicker because YouTube pays you on
a month delay so yeah that's true so
yeah but so thank you guys so much
either way I'll kick this off and then
please as we're doing this stream keep
contributing films that you would like
to see sequels to like right now I'm
seeing in the chat mr. magis saying solo
to an awful lot ties were Saint Hancock
to talk to would be cool um I think the
one sequel that undoubtably sugar I'm
gonna start off with a super obvious one
one that should really get made it would
be showgirls two of Hellboy three I
think in the held wouldn't and I'm
talking about the David Harper version
skip to it goes fans wants I think you
should do
cowboy three Guillermo del Toro Ron
Perlman I undoubtably they both want to
do it and trust me you guys I'm looking
in the chat
I already have some of yours listed here
on my little notepad right here yeah
Hellboy 3 is undoubtably ii I heard this
question it's the one that comes to mind
instantaneously for me because the other
ones that I can sort of think of I I
feel like could maybe one day and once
it's like some people progress a Man of
Steel to turn in this chat and I feel
undoubtedly get done don't feel like
it's going to happen but Hellboy 3 is
one where I'm like we have to champion
for this guy's it could happen if we
champion for it we have to champion for
it that seems like a a fan passion move
yes anything because you know those
first two movies I feel like God made on
Guillermo del Toro's passion and now the
fans got to pick it up about three
because they didn't do as well
absolutely John you got one I would as
somebody actually in the chat has named
a couple of the ones I want first off
buckaroo banzai vs. the world crime
league I would love to see that they
tease that the end of the first film
back in the 80s and Men as a kid I
actually thought it was coming so so I
would love to see that happen in which
it won't but somebody has pointed out
Aleta battle angel and I would love to
see them continue that because I thought
that while that movie wasn't perfect
that's one of the films in recent years
wives had her going there's so much
potential for them to build on that and
do even more with what they already did
the first time and I also always root
for Robert Rodriguez when he gets to be
in the main like film industry so yeah I
would also say Kill Bill Vol 3 yes that
one yes mmm
like I I've been saying for a while now
that if Tarantino were to do is tenth
film and to have that be Kill Bill Vol 3
his most like demanded follow-up sequel
and he's never done like Kill Bill Vol 1
& 2 are already like they're a companion
piece that were shot back-to-back so
it's not it's one of those things where
it's not really a sequel you know it's
more of just the completion of a film
going to yeah but if he were to go out
and be like no guys this is how you do
an actual sequel Tarantino style and if
he did it would kill bill Oh unless it
sucked
and I'd be like remaking goofy movie
sent someone else to do it
for sure but somebody somebody pointed
out 18 - I believe that was Vincent Gray
you are a person after my own heart
because I would love to see a sequel to
the Liam Neeson 18
Goonies - I see Hereafter there are a
lot of names being dropped in here where
I wonder if you guys are serious do you
really want an after earth to Carter
Lovejoy well I I really want a get out
sequel okay just so I could use the
title just so Jordan Peele can take my
title I really have no movie in mind I
just want it to be called get out and
stay out
yeah well let this non black guy write
your follow-up movie yeah yeah that's
well no you could just make it about the
plights of Filipinos you know now that'd
be great and then you could also we can
have a universe you know where we
encompass the pandemic you know in some
kind of social thriller - and call that
stay in comedy back to the future for as
much as I would like to see that happen
no no no I don't think now is anymore is
the time a prequel and I also think
there would be a cool if they did like
their Freddy vs. Jason or Freddy and
Jason versus ash or Freddy vs. Jason
versus ash or Freddy and ash versus
Jason or hash and Jason versus wood ash
in there that'd be great and also if you
guys are here a while
hit the like button if you're in if you
end up enjoying this video that'd be
great
alright let's take a little break here
let's go to this go to the sooner the
people who super chatted us really quick
let's see what we go so we're starting
off with the agoraphobic fanboy OPIC
fanboy whoo Mamma Mia three with a Ryan
Gosling
LOL jk guys from dusk till dawn four or
a reboot with Rodriguez at the helm TV
series doesn't count happy fourth
happy 42 Acorah happy
a fourth of every month you've been here
like every week in agoraphobic I
appreciate that
ponies staying inside you know that's
all you can do when you're good oh we're
seeing a rack and a phobic all these
weeks yeah no he hates spiders too but
well that's the plight of the
agoraphobic because you're inside and
there are spiders and that's also scary
a mama mia three with Ryan Gosling I you
know what it made me think of it I think
you should get a nice guys to with Ryan
Gosling door that yeah and from dusk
till dawn movie and I think we need a
break you know like we already had a few
movies and then you have the TV show
which Rodriguez was at the helm for he
even directed a good chunk of those
episodes at least the first four if I'm
not mistaken two of the first season and
some throughout I like the first I like
the first two seasons and in some ways I
kind of liked the show better the first
season better than the movie and in some
ways there I like things about the show
better than the movie but yeah I would I
would it be I don't think I don't think
right now is the time for another from
nestled on if I'm being totally honest
but I can respect if that's what you
want I don't know I mean maybe they
could make it if they could harness
Robert Rodriguez his sensibility that he
went for after machete where it's like
let's make something wacky and
exploitation II but also that has
something on its mind I feel like you
could do something with from dusk till
dawn in that sense but I also would be
really worried if somebody said they
were gonna revitalize it cuz it's just
not being great since the first movie or
the show in my opinion but all right
who's next on the list thank you a gorf
of a fanboy Thank You Rizzo gaming Ryan
Beatty the man who's always holding down
our discord and he's always encouraging
you guys to hit that [ __ ] like blood
and love that about you
yes spider-man for was Sam Raimi yeah
why is that not on my list I feel
ashamed that was on my list it's okay I
got you and I'm not even joking about
white Savior over here that's right look
out Greg don't worry I can solve all the
races with spider-man
anyone who saw you all I'll kick their
ass with spider-man for Van Helsing -
and the Iron Giant they did her
follow-up - Iron Giant it's called ready
player how they did so good
van Helsing - you know I would come back
I I wouldn't mind a van Helsing reboot
yes and not and not in the [ __ ] like
Blum House cool thing they got going on
right now I was the one with the one
cool movie they got the you know the
Invisible Man I don't want it to be an
action movie but I would like it to be a
little bit bigger than a Blum House a
little bit it's [ __ ] van Helsing you
wanted to be a little action adventure
you would want it to be like Indiana
Jones but horror like overtly yeah
exactly but between your picks for me
spider I think iron Giants perfect and
spider-man for did I don't think you can
properly cap it off with it even if any
of the rumors are to be true about like
Sam Raimi close an awesome a Tobey
Maguire storyline and the multiverse of
madness or whatever this what is it
called the spunk spunk spunk that's
right with that whatever that spider-man
acronym is I always think the word
Sputnik that's a better thing than what
I think of so what do you think of I
think of spunk which is a good quality
to have if you're in America or it's a
you know slang term over yeah baby
batter in the UK yeah I would say I
would say spider-man four will be the
one I'm most champion because like if
we're gonna get like a gazillion a
gazillion different Batman's now and a
bunch of different spider-man movies we
might as well just get that spider-man
four out of the way just cap it off
because I feel like that's another one
that I think people have really been
wanting and let's face it we've heard so
much of what Sam Raimi went through the
poor Santa bring whatever spider-man 3
he deserves a chance to properly cap
that off like spider-man wanted to open
up the door for so much and some people
still hail spider-man to us one of the
greatest comic book movies ever you
might not agree with that I agree with
that statement what do you think John
throwing it to you during this live
stream I agree for the most part I mean
like spider-man 4 is the one that
spiritually I would be like yes Sam
Raimi let's do it bring in Morbius now
that they're making more because I think
that was his original plan but just to
play devil's advocate or to go a
slightly different route I think the one
that would be I would root for as van
Helsing too because it has something to
prove and I still think the concept is
good whereas I've seen a couple really
good Sam Raimi spider-man movies I like
spider-man 3 despite its many flaws and
Iron Giant 2 is one where I'd be like
cool I'll definitely show up it's one of
my very favorite movies but I also don't
feel like it needs it so I yeah III
would probably pay for spider-man 2 but
I would root in my heart for Van Helsing
too but as we're saying this some scene
people in the chat bringing up the
amazing spider-man 3 would you want to
see the amazing spider-man 3 John you
know what I think they should do it's in
order to please everybody they shouldn't
just make one they should just make
everyone so yes I want amazing
spider-man 3 spider-man for spider-man
far from home too you know then it by
toppers sequel spider-man's my homie
which is part four yeah Karen in the
chat showing you a lot of love right now
I've seen sequels to myself and us
through Karen and Mean Girls - so you
guys want my Joker to pitch I'm seeing
that in the chat make sure to go check
out my the latest I think one of the
latest movie fights maybe the last one
just go check it out where I where I
pitched my version of it I like the
people are shouting out sequels that are
definitely like shot and are coming to
where is it go to matrix for I'm like
guys these are you getting your wish
already oh you're fine and then let's
see here Verdugo silver god I've always
loved that name whenever I read it it
sounds like a street in Glendale alright
pressure planet 2 or a live action
Treasure Planet John what do you think
of that job
you know one you know John our old old
dear friend Elsie took me to a like
Disney animation screening of Treasure
Planet back in the dia is that when you
lost your virginity yeah when I was like
11 or whatever that movie came we went
you know I would be down for either/or
of those because I think Treasure Planet
is one of those movies where like even
if it didn't fully connect and it wasn't
all that it could be there's so much
great imagination there and some
beautiful animation there so like I
wouldn't be bummed out for a return to
Treasure Planet in a way that isn't like
one of those odds Treasure Planet 1.5
straight-to-video
you know everything's yeah well there
you go thank you so much for Diego
silver I've never seen Treasure Planet
so I can't properly comment on it but I
appreciate you as I recall Oh Carter
Lovejoy a Carter Lovejoy
always here every week harder Lovejoy
the sequel a sequel to Who Framed Roger
Rabbit would be it would just start off
it would be the same title and it would
just start off and would be Roger Rabbit
pointing at someone going he did it
that's a guy that's the guy we finally
found him then the rest is just a legal
thriller where there's not much drama
because the guy's gonna go away really
hard to watch Roger recount the but a
sequel the Roger Rabbit is something
people have wanted for a very long time
but I kind of wonder if it would I don't
get the impression you know what a lot
of people don't give Roger Rabbit enough
credit for of what really helped make
that work is Bob Hoskins performance
yeah a plus yeah he really helped sell
that world no he's not the animator and
he's not anything enemy two characters
with so much of his performance help
grounded in a sense where you can buy
what's going on his reactions to
everything made it feel lived in the
point where yeah you did it it seemed
like he was really acting with people
who that to a certain extent you know he
carries that movie in a way that is
really easy to forget about because
there are cartoons literally walking
around but yeah like so much of that I
feel like he really is the unsung hero
of that movie he really is so
and a Roger ever to would actually get
people excited for a robert zemeckis
joint and then who'd your place Bob
Hoskins with that Oh Richard star in
there why not like I like it if they got
like one of the super super you know
weird casting where you get like a super
ass edgy comedian and you put them in
some family property like you got like
Dave Chappelle in there or some [ __ ]
kind of kind of ones I would want mm-hmm
and then Thank You gene I love about
Genie super she's never have a question
thank you
I was just watching Tyrone's reaction to
your Tyrone yeah I was watching it - man
yes relations and god I'm gonna do it
thank you for verifying that we are live
yes that is a service and then oh we got
a couple of and then we'll go back to
the chat we just got I love I love all
the pics you guys have so yeah dude look
at look up the backslash of Google I
don't know how what just happened right
it's okay you googled a backslash a clue
of a backslash lost them all right and
then we got a Kyle Sackett over here
over at stream laughs thank you Thank
You Kyle and Lee oh we got a few holy
[ __ ] we got Kyle we got Kyle again we
got Eric let's let's drag that yeah Jon
Jon Jon you got this Jon I so got this
okay here we go Jon fix it Jon
so the losing viewers one of the days he
is out of control
everything's out of control and we're
gonna move Kyle Sacketts to the very
quick I just want to read a quick one
whoever shows up first in my eye here
Mad Max wasteland from galaxy McFly
another madman would be down that's out
- also a good one knives out - is house
have ready that's right whoops might be
my ooh oh I love the pic of Luke Cage
season 3 in the chat yeah bring back all
those I think you should do a defenders
movie cap off all the Netflix characters
that would be my solution there Darren's
also Team America - now is the time and
a real steal - now is the time you guys
have some [ __ ] great picks and
there's something I can't wait to go
through all
these fish - okay here we go Kyle
Sackett Thank You Kyle
I'd be John people Thank You contributor
thank you I'm a dick it's that white
privilege talking right there I know
like you can't just go out of your way
does this a life thank you how does
people giving me money for not doing
this is what being being white is about
getting money for doing nothing so you
know I'm just letting Kyle know that I
appreciate him the white way he's just
insulted 10% of our viewers I would be
happy if only 10% of our viewers were
white I don't know what a white guy
thing is that I'd be on here you win
you're the worst of us you are you are
winning in life but not online realize
it's not in the court of public opinion
I'd be curious instead of a movie sequel
are there any movies you rather see made
into a sequel series or spinoff series
recent video game announcements had me
curious that's an interesting question
a sequel but that's expanded movies that
are made a rather see made into a sequel
series or a spin-off series oh you know
I think it would be cool if we kept Ben
Affleck's Batman his story continuing on
the HBO max program have you pretty neat
or if we got actually you know that
would be pretty [ __ ] cool I wouldn't
mind it the work they doing like at
redstone yes sirree yeah as I remember I
had that idea forever ago and then they
eventually announced it but I never got
around to the actual show mm-hmm but I
always thought that'd be pretty cool but
I think in terms of to answer your
question I think the bottom line is I
think if you're gonna adapt any video
game any almost any video game it's rare
where I could think of a game where I'm
like yeah that should just be a movie
hmm most of them I think should be a TV
show because the amount of time it takes
it even play a video game is longer than
any [ __ ] movie here you could have a
22-episode season with no filler based
off a video exactly if you do a proper
you could honor everything in the game
in a show and you
could also expand upon it and explore it
even more trigger button I'm gonna bring
up a video game The Last of Us if you're
gonna do Last of Us
adaptation the show is the way to do it
and I think if that goes that way for
any like Jordan Vaught Roberts really
wants to do as Metal Gear movie and I'm
really intrigued because he really
really is championing for that Metal
Gear movie and he has like concept art
done and everything but at the same time
I'm like I've played a good chunk of
those Metal Gear games
I haven't played them all but I've
played at least half and I'm like how
can you possibly convert one of these
into a movie it's it seemed it's
impossible you can't do it
oh yeah cuz you're and the missions and
those games are very linear you know
like yeah so much in one place for so
long that even yeah it's like there's no
way to to a proper Metal Gear movie I
don't think like glitchy and the chat is
bringing up Street Fighter right now and
Street Fighter is another one that I'm I
think you know was was a great
adaptation of Street Fighter the anime
show I think the anime shows I should
call it Street Fighter 2 because sequel
when Street Fighter 2 came out that game
can't like that just changed a lot of
fighting games for her for a very long
time and I think even with that the
world the characters and the fact of
like maybe when you play the Street
Fighter games growing up you were just
fighting you weren't that invested in
the storyline but you come to find out
and I think more fighting games go more
into it now than before you all these
characters have a rich lore in a rich
history that you can only properly
explore them in a television format so
yeah I think for any spin-off game to
say the least
you gotta you got to do a [ __ ] that's
the solution and if one TV show
adaptation can pull it off
we're gonna get a whole slew of them
that's the way this business works trust
me I know I talked to the top of the top
I'm on the phone with Jeff Hollywood
every I Geoff Johns and I are best for a
yeah you got a lot control over this yes
they're making a baby driver two people
are camping so much for it in this live
stream they're making one goes Ansel
okay
since don't worry Ezra Miller is still
working antle's gonna keep working
everyone's gonna keep working Armageddon
- I would love to see that face dementia
it's happening it you know be gray if
they didn't Armageddon - and then it was
Bruce Willis still survived and that's
what it's about and he comes back it's
kind of like the ending of fan for stick
where he comes back or seems like the
Armageddon and he comes to the planet
and Liv Tyler has to be like no daddy I
am conflicted what do I do
I don't know my dad but you're also a
meteor and humanoid format it's a great
chance for Bruce Willis ofone inane
again because he just like it when he
does he has to play a meteor human you
know how great would that be
you know what I think would work
actually as a spin-off series instead of
trying to do another sequel movies
Jurassic Park I would do a Jurassic Park
the show rather than the movie because I
think you can just do more I think you
could do what you would have done in any
movie and also more in a show
environment that's maybe like ten
episodes or eight episodes you're
something lost me they lost me John well
you know that's my goal I'm all for uh
you know subjective opinions and all but
you can go [ __ ] yourself with that guy
drastic part ghostbusters I would rather
see a ghostbusters show than another
Ghostbuster I think they should reboot
Straight Outta Compton as an all-female
cast yes why can't there be a female
easy and a female Ice Cube a female DJ
ran a bull call call me by my name [ __ ]
thirty-one sequels is called thirty and
then what's this next one yeah there we
go
and second thing for another one buddy
that's a say thank you before you read
someone contributing oh wow this was
enlightening
I'm Dez John thank rhodesia we're
thinking goddammit yeah as for movie
sequels I'd love to see a blade for with
Wesley Snipes in an alternate MCU
universe or as a one-off
rated R film also Boondock Saints 3
would could be entertaining that it
would be and plus that director needs it
it's the only call he's allowed to make
I don't know if you guys know about that
director store anybody is only allowed
it pretty much make Boondock Saints
movies how's that going for him right
now yeah I would love to see a blade for
to some extent knowing the way how
compact movies are going now once we get
this new marchiali blade movie off the
ground soon there'll be a blade verse
okay and then what Leslie snaps appear
in that blade movie and then we're gonna
be set and everyone's gonna be a happy
camper you have nothing to worry about
that's the main concern with comic book
movies now is I'm like okay it's gonna
be like the actual books in the future
where you have like a whole bunch of
different series that are like team ups
and solos all running at the same time
and the only unfortunate part is that
you know wesley snipes or Tobey Maguire
or you know some of these guys might die
before they get their chance to come
back very true oh goodness
so we do one more from the streams
before we go I will do I'll do two moral
and then then we're gonna just take a
break from the the chat so you guys have
been sending our way which we really do
appreciate Eric the horseman thank you
dude thank you that's a major
contribution buddy bang on as expected
we're at the point now where we can't be
like Eric don't break your wallet now
we're at the point with Eric where it's
like I expect nothing less
yes and this this is actually a comment
below 50 Eric I'm gonna be like what the
[ __ ] is this bow you're really you're
really letting yourself slippery to get
arrogant stop dude we have you we don't
restraining order living in Kobe we
appreciate any contribution that comes
our way don't break don't sweat it
seriously okay it's okay because Eric
horseman has to say thank you Eric
horseman chameleon that should have been
done it's enter from Lee Scott scrap
sequels sorry for shouting Wow should
have given viewers a heads up there you
go to yell this is not live I put my
mouth away from the mic now live you're
gonna hurt how many times we get
complaints about her audio already all
the time I read all the time I know I
read them too I know we never know we
don't do anything
this was on my list shouted or not
bleeding ears are not Neil Blomkamp's
alien five was definitely on my list of
sequels I wish had come to fruition I
agree this is the 980 the thing about
Eric's super chats is most of the time
when he contributes something he always
says something I'm like this should have
gotten done but the good news is Alien
and Predator are now with Marvel so we
can get more pg-13 properties so does
the exciting thing hyoeun man vs.
predator written directed by Shane Black
ooh that would make everyone happy it
would make every not both of those
beloved in their respective franchise
way to go so beloved and then it's just
one more and then yeah I'm we're gonna
do a speed round of all the picks that
you guys have in I I've been over to him
I'm looking at the super Chan stuff is
looking at what you guys have been
putting down you guys have some awesome
[ __ ] picks I don't know we're gonna
be riffing on Pat yourselves on the back
while we read from Ethan Holgate thank
you my darling hi guys very happy you
loved the last of us part 2 Greg you are
part of the 70% of people that are glad
I did so did I much an amazing Saturday
is such an amazing story and game also
sequels I'd like to see would be a
leader to Hancock - I am Legend - after
earth 2 after 2 his Legend of Bagger
Vance - 7 yeah oh yeah I am legend -
shame they came say shame they chose the
wrong ending lul upgrade to would be
awesome what are some sequels you want
to see well I mean we're gonna be naming
some of our sarasu I appreciate you
contributing you're Ethan ok there's one
that I've saw coming very early on in
this chat sexy that I have second on my
list which is sky height
skyhigh I think is a completely
underrated entry into live-action Disney
that I thought would be a big pile of
[ __ ] and I loved that I loved it I think
I like watched it twice in the theaters
yeah I got and was like reviewing
anything it just really loved the movie
and I wanted to go watch it again
skyhigh 2 is one that I really hope hey
I just hope more people watch skyhighone
I need to do that I'm letting you down
[ __ ] I know it has some surpassing all
the Jeepers Creepers I've only seen the
first one and I hate that it's decent
but yeah I mean but I like your pics
Hancock - and I'm surprised to talk -
hasn't happened cuz that's another one
of those movies that had like tons of
potential and is like pretty good for
parts of it and just has some areas
where I fully nail it and so yeah I
would love to see Hancock I would have
loved the anchors it's it baffles me how
Peter Berg always seems like he has a
sequel that he's going to do and it
never comes true him and Mark Wahlberg
both just he's generally speaking do not
yeah so but I appreciate the question I
appreciate your picks I love all that
all the ones that you said for it but
guys let's see what's going on right
here in the stream okay I got this John
oh thanks I'm gonna kind of stare into
the cam don't you fret alright while you
do that okay let's see what are we
talking about here what are we talking
about Man of Steel - of course that's
going to happen guys don't worry madam
steel will happen it'll have just make
petitions alright DC listens to
petitions just make more petitions it's
more petitions tech $5 under your
petitions signature and you might get
something made even quicker than you
expect I'm seeing here in the chat Jango
- Django Unchained - damn you - Django
you know there was like a graphic novel
or sonic on book where it's Django meet
Zorro or Ginga versus oral something
like that I actually think that would be
a great idea like that's the cool thing
about the kind of worlds Tarantino
builds is you hear that and you're like
I could see Tarantino making there I
could see he put Sonny Chiba in [ __ ]
a Kill Bill yeah
you know and I think he can pull off
jingo going toe-to-toe with Zorro yeah
yeah that we cool man yeah like I would
actually or or them even just like you
know at first being adversaries and then
teaming up for something like I would I
would be down for either yam let's see
here Oh
eighth-grade now we are at ninth grade I
like that Kevin shippers Constantine you
could actually do a sequel to eighth
grade I bet you could you could do
something where they're like Krista ends
off where she ends junior high you can
do some where she's starting high school
like it's a whole other thing where you
go four years later or you do like one
of those David Linklater Richard
Linklater things and you do one with
Elsie Fisher buh-burn Murray teams where
she's like in like 20 years and she
grows daily like a thirty year old you
know before our very eyes yeah I know
I'm saying you just do
ninth grade where she's like twenty
years old we would have done that anyway
I mean we wouldn't be able to start
shooting until she's at least twenty
they should do an eighth my like
Carter's saying nine mile this year
eight mile two with a mile and get rich
or die trying' where they cross over I
see a thousand words to from a glutton
for punishment and I think you got a
shot this Donovan camp common Donovan is
the end to set in 2020 if they could man
like that is that is one movie I would
be like yeah start production whatever
to do it the other guys too
yes it surprises also support katha me
yeah how we got a daddy's home to get
the other guys why not it seems somehow
more marketable but I don't know um you
got to get a godfather for obvious
definitely you got to get a Schindler's
List to where Schindler comes back from
the dead I would I would I want them to
Chandlers addendum you hear those jokes
all the time like Titanic - or Scarface
- why haven't someone just had the balls
to go and just go [ __ ] it we're doing
this let's try when Bruce Lee died there
were like Hong Kong films of like Bruce
Lee back from the
people played Bruce oh yeah why can't we
do that with just like make these
terrible [ __ ] schlocky ass movies
we're like Scarface is a zombie here's
some pain and it's the goal is to still
take over Florida
that's what the asylum should be doing
why not Oh like this is the kind of
thing like we need our own production
company so that we can waste money on
this nonsense
Constantine Taurus you constantine's
another one that I see a lot of love for
they should get more twenty eight months
later that's one for sure and Maria
Hammond it is Saturday
just check your calendar well dude it's
because she probably got the
notification bell where it's it's
Saturday night yeah and so some people
were like oh this must be a premiere
video where it's gonna go live outside
I'm gonna sit here and wait for the
premiere for 24 hours I know I know I
know
rush hour for directed by Brett Ratner I
I don't want a rush hour for I do want a
Shing right on yeah that was the title
they gave forever ago still hasn't come
out and I heard like a vague like maybe
it'll happen again like recently but
yeah I really wish it would I think I
think Owen Wilson and Jackie Chan are
both in a position where they could way
they could do it real rejects - yeah
place you a Patrick Hogue yeah he's a
better version we got a better 28 years
later that's another one that I'm
surprised hasn't been done yeah I mean
Danny Boyle was willing to let that
franchise go right away I don't know why
they haven't it you know normally it's
like if we have a good story but what
people like 28 weeks later I know why
haven't they done it I don't know
someone's slacking off get get Alex
Garland on the horn hey guys we're gonna
go back to super Chet's and just admit
if I wanted to say another one really
fast
trick or treat yeah I wanted to say we
should get what what the hell's on my
list here ooh okay
World War Z - ooh we should get a prize
I was very excited at the prospect of
David Fincher doing a zombie movie with
Brad Pitt their work together is awesome
David Fincher always brings a wonderful
psychological angle to it I don't know
exactly
what happened but the fact that it's not
happening anymore is a real bummer to me
somebody just commented 28,000 years
later which eventually would be like the
six sequels surviving the Sun and blowed
sunshine get Killian Murphy back if you
got to hear make sure to hit that like
button let's go back to the Super chats
down what do we got the game lover thank
you so much thank you game love
appreciate you showing your support and
living up to the game lovers name I love
The Last of Us - it's a masterpiece no
it's bad no I would wait it's a
masterpiece no it's it's is it's it bad
no would I give it a ten out of ten no
what I give an eight I feel the bad
reviews are from religious people so
okay so eight out of ten in the
batteries or religious I'll be a
religious folk but the game lovers still
loves this game so so yeah and a main I
mean I something tells me that religious
folk may make up for a small margin of
the people who are against the game but
I have a feeling it's a different group
I'm very I'm very much like I'm with the
Last of Us - so many people want me to
like not so many but a good handful the
people want me to do videos with them on
it and and I'm like do everyone I don't
know if I want to man become the Last of
Us guy i I really avoided every review
for that like the actual reviews and
they were coming out I avoided every
review especially while I was playing
the game and before I even uploaded our
review yesterday I was like I'm not I'm
not reading or listening to any review
because I don't want any of other
people's opinions like intercepting my
brain and [ __ ] with me basically
because that game has developed such a
unique passion that I love experiencing
when it's especially when I'm like oh I
really am feeling passionate about it
whether it be positive or negative
because it is like there are some things
where people hate it and I'm like I
don't get
I don't get why you hate it and this is
one of those games where like 3/4 of the
way through this 30 hour gameplay
experience I was like I really get why
people hate this game and I also really
get why people love this game and some
people think you'll be like a fun debate
time for me to like debate with you
though like someone who doesn't like I'm
like I don't want I'm not interested in
that man I just wanna like what the game
my [ __ ] money yeah if you want my
opinion it's enough 55 minute video like
watch that [ __ ] you know I I'm sorry to
break from the super chest but I did
have to shout out rizzo gaming set an
eight-mile sequel which i think is a
terrific idea
because you know i really want to see a
movie about mmm trying to figure out why
people don't respect music as much as
that thank you guys so much thanks team
lover lover never lose your nerd thank
you so much heard heard of the word
elite a battle angel Anita yes sir mana
otherwise I would happen with half the
budget
God if only fans with signed petitions
for that movie Katie automatically to
battle angels were you just skipping
right over that [ __ ] just move right
over it let's talk more about a legal
battle okay I was I was teasing I was
like well maybe we'll lose him not we're
never gonna lose our third we're never
gonna lose our you know that I know
right most times alone our chats are
like oh thanks cool nope and then move
on no no we'll take we spent 40 minutes
on each one there's a reason these are
way too long but yeah lead a battle to
that I really did enjoy opening day and
we did talk about Elena battle angel
earlier so we already covered let's move
on yes agreed
Katie Orlando Orlando back in the chat
hi Katie could see her yeah thank you
hitchhikers guide us hereditary and
district
whoa those are like two out of four of
those are movies where I just can't
imagine a sequel and two of them were
I'm like definitely I am too I'm going
to slightly spoil us slightly if you
haven't seen it but I just feel like the
sequel would be the boy talking hit
Lupita Nyong'o son the whole movie just
watching his mom going you my mom my
[ __ ] mom through this once before I
don't trust you
eh I saw some weird [ __ ] underground at
that one goddamn amusement park you my
mom I found myself in the ancient
Wizards cave or whatever that's all I
would imagine there but oh good the
simple police are here to arrest Simpson
what hereditary to be I guess weed
Hitchhiker's Guide works great because
they're like hella books in that series
district nine should have gotten a
sequel and district 9 is the one out of
all of these where if they did a like
many years later sequel and took
advantage of the many years later aspect
of that I actually would be totally fine
with the gap I guess yeah because that's
a movie where I loved it it's great it's
crisp and yeah I would love like a
decade or 20 years down the lines he
pulled of that I agree with you John you
know pineapple Express to be grand
especially now that marijuana is mostly
legal state yeah that's the only reason
I want to go on the Joe Rogan show just
to [ __ ] them and be like let me tell you
what weeds wrong and then after he yells
at me for twenty minutes I'd be like I'm
just kidding buddy pack that bowl Joey
game lover is back and the game lover
wants the Last of Us movie out of
development he'll dude you're gonna get
a show and trust me it's gonna be way
better than what any movie would have to
offer it's gonna be the best a must-see
this is what a completely different
route you know what I mean
definitely Peter Pacheco thank you Peter
Pacheco always happy to see your Captain
Spaulding face in our chat yeah an
always regrettably not having learned
that Portuguese accent watch men Const
oh no
wait we're skipping ugh okay girlfriend
says sucker punch
trick-or-treat Scott Pilgrim valyrian
and the city of a thousand planets much
ethic kills again in space
alright John take it away which one do
you want a sequel to you there all right
I want trick-or-treat
definitely machete kills again in space
yeah they set it up
I want it was nice in that Leonardo
DiCaprio right yes I want that [ __ ] and
I and I hope that enough time has passed
where they can tighten it up past
machete kills cuz I liked machete more
than machete kills Scott Pilgrim there
are hella books in that series so sure
bring Scott Pilgrim back definitely uh
Valyrian didn't see the actual movie so
I'm neutral and Sucker Punch I have seen
I wouldn't I I wouldn't be excited but I
wouldn't be opposed like the movie is
beautiful looking and not that fun to
watch and he would need some kind of
overall in the tone yeah I'm really
excited for a sucker punch - yeah but
trick-or-treat is is probably my
favorite just because there's so much
you can do and it's one of the few
Halloween movies it's about Halloween
tradition Halloween time imagery etc so
like I feel like that offers you a lot
well you can always do an anthology
movie follow up a trick-or-treat and
always keep it at Halloween you know
okay just go to a different city or
state or something like that you can't
keep that franchise going forever but no
I just bring back the same back all the
same character back who in the chat
wanted to [ __ ] love that that is a
great no idea I wanted to hasn't come
out thank you for mentioning that sham
good call and shout out to Danny
Elfman's uh little things song from that
movie because I still bump that Jam
you don't really quick you know what I
think a wanted to hasn't come out is
because all the attention about that was
well Angela okay guys I'm gonna spoil
water for you Angelina Jolie gets shot
in the head alright
Fox is her name right she's Fox what's
Morgan Freeman's character's name okay
whatever Lee's Fox who in the comics I
believe is a black girl and that
interesting
so I think Angela jelly she gets killed
in that movie and so much the and James
McAvoy wasn't you know as famous as he
is now hmm so I think a lot of people
like what a doing it if Angelina Jolie's
not around but guys James McAvoy is
awesome in that movie yeah and he really
goes from this like pitiful cowardly
dude into a real badass by the end of
the movie so and I wanted sequel and why
is it your wanted sequel even in
development what's going on are you
doing one I'm just I'm doing a little
bit of chatroom moderation at the moment
that's all we need to get a moderator I
know I don't know how it works
a username that somebody was not too
pleased that and I'm trying to see if
there's a trouble a-brewin and that I
need to talk what are you talking about
it was a comment from n/a a shoot oh Sh
why this beautiful Bliss guy can go
himself with a cactus well if he pops up
will get look beautiful bliss like this
is you're too distracted man sorry
Disney star wars beautiful bliss is bags
oh he is hey beautiful bliss what's up
man okay beautiful say you were
searching for beautiful bliss in the
chat oh yeah in a real dumb day it had
six that night differently we do control
f and it has a key word bliss and it was
all in the super chasse this whole time
yeah okay so I were like ooh I know
right and I was like always super time
wait a minute a time move backwards guys
well beautiful bliss I still love you
until I find a reason I shouldn't Disney
star wars remake is what you love you're
not alone I'll give you that beautiful
bliss is kind of like that idea I love
doing that video that's why my favorite
video we filmed all week
oh god yes I did really have a blast
shooting and listening back to that
video that's because that one is like
well I sometimes I'm like what do I put
in the title of this thumbnail and then
I was Irish think well this does sound
stupid but I really do want it at the
same time yeah why don't we just put
that in the thumb you guys haven't heard
this like ridiculous rumor going around
about them doing a like remaking star
like not making the latest trilogy canon
and then making a new nine it's a silly
idea like it's so stupid and I really
think it is just a rumor I don't think
there's actual like real credibility to
it that being said if it is being
plotted if it is being considered I
would love to see it I just would love
to watch it become a club even more of a
cluster in the show yeah at this point I
would love for it to be a [ __ ]
show and yeah I'll be there yeah watch
Disney burn star wars to the crew yeah
what watch Disney get all Warner Bros
about this yeah I'd hate it too at the
same time but I'd also love it it would
be all the emotions all wrapped up in a
one beautiful burrito of a movie sounds
like a nice experience and then Michael
Swift Miguel I hear thank you that they
were working on a sequel to don't
breathe I've heard this too I would
definitely be down to see it I mean if
Eddie Alvarez is somebody whose name I
always look out for unless it's I didn't
actually see the girl in the spiders
they would call it stop breathing hold
your breath hold your breath keep not
breathing breathe through your nose
um we'll get there we'll get to a funny
one oxygen again 21 right here during a
live brainstorm session right yeah it'll
be called them pipes they ended in a way
where you could get a sequel mm-hmm yeah
yeah it would just be but I was you
again
it would be those two without in the
open would he be like on an adventure
going through I would actually love you
know what I would love if he did a
sequel to don't breathe and you did it
for Stephen Lang yes he did from Stephen
Lang's perspective okay not a bad guy I
think if he was like the setting out on
some type of revenge mission yes I mean
that's what he's doing alright really
cool my managers right here Karen don't
worry Karen's in love with you
beautiful bliss let's do one more from
the supers and then maybe do a stream
lab here beautiful bliss series of
unfortunate events you got a whole TV
show man you did get a shot team
everything for it I appreciate the
superjet and I like both there's a whole
TV show and I did I generally think
we're TVs at now a lot of times
generally I think adaptations for the
most part are kind of better in a TV
show format for the most part I would
say so you know yeah I would agree with
that you just have especially from like
book source material you have so much
more room to spread your yeah their
wings in your legs and all your
appendages people already want a quiet
place three and fast and furious number
fifty it's really time all right so we
got Kyle Sackett back on the stream Labs
page thank you so much thank you John
Sackett very excited for the Last of Us
series project at HBO as well as fallout
I just heard about this very excited
going to fall out
yeah the Jonathan Nolan and the woman
who helps that I think they just
announced yesterday but yeah it's
Jonathan Nolan and the other woman who
created West world together or creating
it of course you know the guys name but
I feel really bad about that but since
you but you don't know the woman I don't
and I thought about that why pray love
town yours again that's right
I just hope that Jonathan Nolan's a
great filmmaker he's got point that out
he is he's great sure who better way
better than whoever that woman because
of his dick very excitable as was just
[ __ ] around I hope that I'm gonna
assume this is the Last of Us series
that they can keep the character
development arcs on par with the game
also one last movie Abe Lincoln vampire
hunter - that'd be fun
I was same guy who did want it you know
I had I don't like that movie as much as
wanted but I did enjoy it more than I
thought I ought to have so III would be
down for anybody 500 you
I like that pic yeah I like that big
that's a great one and I don't know I
think the loss of a series whatever
happened I think they could probably do
a lot of what's the [ __ ] word I'm
looking for retroactive continuity maybe
tell you like make up for what's the
word I'm trying in that course
correction but like supplemental
material basically hot or something to
fill in the gap yeah well yeah you could
I don't know the events of the last of
us - but I'm sure that you could expand
or have Joel be a presence you know in a
different way to be so funny just to
piss off the audience even more is if
they cast Joel but they made him like a
transgender woman or a trans man or
transmitter transmitting it doesn't
matter just any anybody anybody just
just to watch the uproar a queer black
trend a queer black trans woman should
play should play so just just to really
really see everybody twist around I
guess I honestly can't remember the last
time I I was a part of like I am part of
the fan outrage I don't remember the
last time I genuinely was like there
were times I'm like what the [ __ ]
or like I'm baffled yeah yeah but the I
don't know the last one was like such
[ __ ] I just laugh at fan outrage
yeah last time I I'm trying to think of
the last time I was outraged as a fan I
the closest I probably came was BVS and
I just left theater
I wasn't enraged I was glum just like
there's no excuse for this I'll get an
Aquaman - what would up to be about he's
trying to resurrect it's a fantasy world
anything happened never lose your nerd
let's do one more from you The Prodigy -
the way it ended was cool and unexpected
The Prodigy with with is that the movie
with like Elijah Wood as like a crazy
brilliant child Nora Jon I got this get
it hey Siri what is the prodigy movie
it's a biopic of the band The Prodigy it
says do I want to call Carmen or
FaceTime Adriana
apparently it might the characters of
the soprano how do you engage with the
soprano okay we're gonna look up The
Prodigy the old-fashioned way we're
gonna avoid 2019 film yes do not smack
my [ __ ] up it'sit's something else it's
yeah all right here we go The Prodigy
2019 is a horror film with a little
child crazy boy yes okay it was better
than what everyone thought it would be
yeah yeah it was like pitches like a
cliche piece of [ __ ] and then it ended
up being like actually really good yeah
yeah mm-hmm oh this guy's done a couple
movies that I've heard are pretty decent
very cool uh yeah I can't speak to it
but I'm always down for a good horror
sequel what about a kick-ass three I'd
be open to it I didn't like kick us to
very much but I definitely be open to
that world - yeah like I feel like kick
ass is like property where just if time
has passed and you come back sure new
[ __ ] could be happening what about crank
three down and especially down for good
burger - what about hold on you know you
know I think oh why didn't I mention
that jumper jumper is an underrated
movie oh okay I think they just really
love doug liman your thing I think I've
liked every entity is the best one I'm
pretty sure of like every Doug Liman
okay you are the man's fan club I'm glad
doug liman has a fan Mars Attacks - heck
yeah oh my god
oh you know what I really want I want a
bath I want a Batman proper Batman 3
with Michael Keaton a returner under the
helm of Tim Bergen do it
bet Dark Knight Rises Batman Beyond
style oh I like it I like it a lot
ok Beetlejuice - my god I've worked on a
whole pitch like that with Andrew ah
John what Oh Erik or email one more from
err I expect nothing less
yes this is what I expect from you
Thank You Erik Erik says to Wong foo
thanks for nothing JK Rowling
what I actually just watched too long
food thanks for everything Julie Newmar
to Wong foo is the movie with Patrick
Swayze Wesley Snipes and John Leguizamo
when they all play drag queens and yeah
I literally just watched this again like
a great weeks ago it's topical I mean it
doesn't have the greatest reviews but I
do enjoy it quite a bit it's very feel
good and it's very you know it's very
what's the word accepting cathartic sure
yes - on a few things for nothing JK
Rowling I would on the title alone I
would buy a ticket just yeah that's a
great call Thank You Erik Thank You
Eddie they should do a JK Rowling like
they should do I hope a biopic of JK
Rowling get like Tilda Swinton to star
in it and it should start off right at
the point where she got Twitter they
should cast a trans actors to play just
to really twist things up a little bit
just get like a terrific transaction
just be like oh hey man anybody can play
anybody Asgard Jo is to be believed now
you don't need another you don't need
another
Harold and Kumar we don't need another
Harold and Kumar those are done
I would JK rowling sorry JK Rowling side
I I would be interested in a cursed
child movie as much as I would feel
conflicted about giving her money
anymore Judge Dredd - with Stallone oh
we should get the Dredd verse doing
addres diverse and then we can have both
and then eventually they can cross over
and have Stallone meet Karl Urban that
would be - do you write I mean honestly
I would love just call her burdens - the
lone starring in a movie together so
early is like badass [ __ ] American
accent that he does - he has a badass
everything was except when his bones he
doesn't sound badass when he's speaking
is pretty badass he's a badass character
just his voices what am i a doctor
pretty like he has kind of got this
old-fashioned wave he's gonna wear ja
that old-fashioned American thing but
Karl Urban xanax courage where he's not
really that wacky Abood oblivion to be
guy's gosh yeah we there's absolutely no
way you could do it oblivion - what the
[ __ ] am i talkin just more Tom Cruise's
who elf - that would be awesome
oh you know I was enough time passage
yeah I really feel like everyone loves a
Will Ferrell does that's not one of his
mainstream big popular movies but
whenever he does something that's more
under like under the radar like this
random Eurovision movie yeah people
really like him it's bizarre anybody
else - that was the elf
it was an amazing was oh it was an
interesting experience at the box office
I remember that because no one really
thought I'd be that good people end up
loving and it opened up at number two
and then it's like second week I climbed
up yeah you know I've seen a couple
movies do that over time and it's always
like True Grit was another one the Coen
Brothers one where it climbed up after
like it opened it three or something
like that and then two weeks later it
was number one for like four weeks
straight
you guys remember that feeling of when a
random original movie comes out
when it's not based off a comic book or
a sequel and then it just stays number
one at the box office for so long yeah I
want to see splice - I do - mwo see
ghost 74 X Oh a jiff tomorrow - why the
[ __ ] is that not an efficient like guys
yeah it works today make it work
Tom Cruise's died repeat he never don't
mess with the Zohan - is a movie I would
pay for Ace Ventura 3 would you be down
for job come back no no
Goonies - while they're all older sounds
like a great idea Ferris Bueller's Day
Off
he's just an adult skipping work you
know at some meeting and the boss is
calling his name Bueller Bueller and his
boss should be Cameron see remember that
day we missed we skip work Cameron took
my dad we should do it again I'm your
boss Ferris do you know how bad this
make me look Ferris
dude I love those kinds of sequels -
like some sequels are great because they
have such an inspired reason to continue
and some sequels are great because they
absolutely don't have to and sometimes
leaning into that frivolity is is like a
nice way of loosening yourself up wait
is today Tom Cruise's birthday hold on
you know I saw Scott Mann's post a
picture of him and that would explain
why hey Siri when is Tom Cruise's
birthday I like Carter Lovejoy's getting
Bill and Ted four in early July thirties
58 years old a Tom Cruise he should do
Passion of the Christ to replace Jim
Caviezel with Tom Cruise Passion of
Christ cruise he gets off that cross and
starts running runs they should remain
patient of Christ he runs up the Rainbow
Bridge to heaven I'm not kidding all
right as good as sound like I'm making
some insensitive joke as an adult I when
I was a little boy
and I was a very devoted Catholic and I
first started to like wonder if I want
her to be a writer one of my ideas was
this wasn't like a joke movie this was
like this would be a badass movie of
Christ getting because I was I was
obsessed with the movie Jesus Christ
Superstar and I really loved that movie
and I was like it would be cool if we
did a movie where Jesus got off the
cross and he got revenge and I thought
that was an actual good idea then I was
like insanity it's still a good idea and
now it just sounds like I'm a man close
to being 30
he's making an insensitive ass your gun
but it would be a movie hocus pocus to I
don't know if it would work now but I
would love it I would be happy to see it
yeah they should do a Lex Luthor movie
starring what's-his-name the [ __ ] guy
who was now reporter Kevin Spacey back
Brad singer to helm which guy was mean
to reporter [ __ ] Jesse Eisenberg
Jesse Eisenberg yes definitely that's
that's why Oh using the mug Anissa gave
yeah nieces mug there you go Tintin I'm
surprised for how much not in the States
as much but in the world Tintin is a
pretty big phenomenon so I'm surprised
we don't have more Tintin let's catch up
on some super chats John's CA TCH don't
worry we'll get a Jumanji for its you'll
be fine don't worry
Lincoln to link again [ __ ] linked up
Alexandre life is covered don't you
worry
Alexandre Deller disco in a video game
thank you in a video game perspective
Mad Max Payne and Shenmue or Shenmue a
Oh like a sequel the Max Payne that's
what I'm guessing you would they be fun
so if we're talking about in a video
game perspective do you just mean like
video game movies because they have made
at least a Max Payne movie or are you
just talking about you would want to see
sequel video games to these yeah I mean
Shenmue is already a franchise yeah I
don't know much about Shenmue but like
oh I'm the biggest Shenmue fan I'm just
trying to see what they would share do
you know that's seventy seven percent of
Google users like Shen me it seems like
citing this my hand it didn't just pop
up in my frame it seems like it would be
a lot of up a lot of people's alley but
just not you know everyone's Ali's 70%
is indicative of that I mean in it let
me tell you about Shin year that I know
of mine is always got him Hazuki oh I
know it so well it starts off in 1987 oh
wow and he's searching probably for his
father's killers what I would guess yes
his father's coming lon
okay yeah and it's not real and you're
an open world called GUI Lin wow we
should write the Wikipedia page sometime
I would love to see sequels to
everything every sequel to these things
but would you still cast mark wallace
says check keys in the chat right now
he's saying check my next superjet okay
but I will check it all right we will
but thank you Thank You Alexander Peter
Pacheco back at BAC k watchman
Constantine John wick and as an oak cats
too or grease three somebody who would
definitely want to see a grease three
who uh several of my musical theater
friends but myself personally a great
answer but I would I want cats to set
the [ __ ] up out of that grease well
mainly mainly might know someone who
would mainly my friend Haley would love
but also I know a few people who are
greased to apologists who would also
love that but mainly my homegirl in the
TN I would love cats too though I would
be all about the butthole cut of cats
too and Constantine Watchmen I don't
know if you could really continue
Watchmen without you know you can wonder
no I'm saying without setting yourself
up to fall short of that mark because
like the show
remember sling I don't know this is
gonna hit the Mart anything that's like
following up Watchmen so like I do that
show is the best show last year right
next a better call Saul yeah which is
why I'm saying you would need oh I'm a
sequel to The Watchmen show would be
legit a sequel to The Watchmen movie I
don't know so much yeah I'll be great I
would released a snare you can watch sir
our Butler do the Mariner [ __ ]
oh dude Simpsons movie - why haven't we
got in that that's a [ __ ] to make but I
would love us in sin sequel king of the
hill movie for the first time they
should make a nut you know I think now
would be the perfect time for a South
Park sequel yes it would because really
what they would make the most [ __ ] up
jokes in this time and they could get
away with it now is it and we need a few
we need those few mediums as few people
who can get away with [ __ ] up Joe I'm
telling you they're bringing they've
already confirmed to bring it back
beavis and butt-head they're bringing
back really yeah and III like I was just
talking with Eric about this the other
day is like shows like that would be so
perfect to come back now and like king
of the hill is one of them at South Park
is another one and they're still on I
love another South Park movie it'd be
out like South Park as a movie to do
what they did with that movie yeah now
would be the perfect time yeah exactly
we got nerd chronic Eric a chronic
moment thank you Eric for Eric because
Eric does a lot of cool [ __ ] but he also
cuts the badass awesome Schmo down
intros and all sorts of stuff for the
Schmo down but like he's added it for us
to sedative for us for our watch along
as the guy is a life saver and he never
sleeps and we pay him pennies we don't
pay him well pay him and we abuse him
verbally in microwavable rice beads as
well we pay that [ __ ] ring yeah and
that he we pay him less than the super
chat that he just gave [ __ ] Eric's
incredible and he's helped us out in a
lot more ways and you guys would like
there he's up the side in so many ways I
can't even begin to mention like I don't
think you'd want me to mention a couple
of things before reactions to help me
relax and ease
jerk me off man he helped me hide that
body
he's my heroin hookup yeah awesome throw
down match this week Greg oh oh I get
what you're doing guys go watch my road
a match
yes first Mike killer's mouse key and
it's my favorite Schmo now match I've
ever been a part of none with this guy
is there any time I'm in a mattre job
it's always like man John needs a new
partner or a man remember John the
free-for-all so this one's my favorite
match and then people were still like
man's real rejects but John no and thank
you for the wishes of luck for next week
I am sure that my match will be better
than Greg it's okay man you're that free
for all a few years ago yeah so I
literally don't hurt I wish I felt that
way because every time I walk into one
of these matches now I'm like why did I
have to do that and not live up to it
dude oh not my guy my guy my guy what's
up buddy me a guy from NZ is that New
Zealand New Zealand New Zealand not sure
if it's it before but I'm giant showing
more of where it came from
so you do the Iron Giant see the problem
is now I've heard so many Australian
people and I've heard so many Kiwis talk
that like I know some of the finer
details but it's hard to mess with that
accent yeah
Iron Giant - is is like a really tricky
prospect to me cuz my my favorite films
of all time I would be curious to see
his home place I would just be like so
nervous going into that movie ok alright
ok
everyone's a lot of people in this chant
I've been talking about an Iron Giant -
let me pitch to you how I think you
should do an Iron Giant - you do it eh
not animated you do a live-action and
and and then instead of getting like a
CGI version of the Iron Giant
you just put Vin Diesel in the role and
he has a white wife beater the whole
time right because that's the way we
like Vin Diesel people forget the Vin
Diesel voice the Iron Giant
and then instead of a little boy that
he's know what you do with the Disney
formula you do the Disney formula where
what's the little boy's name in that
movie Hogarth
Hogarth has now grown up and he lives up
a miserable life financially Barbara
knees the fans wife doesn't appreciate
any of these kids who he hasn't got time
for [ __ ] chill the kids just want to
love their daddies one day an Iron Giant
chose back he's gonna save the day at
the business office
[ __ ] you dude yeah I think that's the
direction we should go especially on the
heels of the great treatment the irony
I'm being you know it's the way we go
it's the way it would be okay we'll work
I'm down let's do it
I love a verb and then and then when
Hogarth shoots his boss at the end he
goes I am NOT a gun this is a gun
beautiful bliss is back lethal weapon
thank you with Mel Gibson and Danny
Glover you have been talking about your
Lethal Weapon 5 are different I know but
then they did [ __ ] blood father which
is a great title and they did the Lethal
Weapon TV show which was underrated but
then that guy got fired from for being a
person you know weirdly I read a lot
about that story and I can never get a
conclusive thing because there was a lot
of like comparisons there was a lot of
compelling stuff of people being like I
don't know clean Crawford's pretty great
and a lot of people being like I don't
know Damon Wayans just didn't give a
[ __ ] and they didn't get along and he
wanted him off the show and blah blah so
I have no idea
well I think okay Lethal another Lethal
Weapon movie would I just be depressing
at this Danny Glover is too like Danny
Glover is satisfied to be on set at this
point for that long and a lead with that
kind of and I wouldn't want to see him
like how this Danny Glover Oh
John you wouldn't want to Lethal Weapon
movies hey Siri how old is danny glover
is his earring all with get away with it
[Laughter]
means 70 makes all the difference
hi 70 he Dooley Harrison Ford can like
cats really well but the thing is like
Harrison Ford like they gave a lot of
his action [ __ ] to Shia LaBeouf or to
kylo Ren look at the attention nice
against attention there she is oh she
just sent the superchips let's move
forward
let's keep everyone Tiffany Hoffman
Lethal Weapon oh sorry I was keeping
only the one and the truth be told it
like I think Mel Gibson will forever be
in purgatory he is because he was
cancelled at a time before we had
precedent ever it seems like we're about
to forget about it no one wants you to
forget about it that's the thing and you
know what I'm not gonna say if that's
the right thing to do or the wrong thing
to do because honestly it's probably the
right thing to do and I just don't want
it to be that way yeah that's the sad
part
so people always wanna like we don't
want to let it and we should we and I
don't really want to have this
discussion right now I just don't think
that this is the place to solve this
this is the place a YouTube lives this
is where we're gonna solve it for
everyone in America we're about to solve
this but yeah I think I don't know I
mean like tip for him to just do a
sequel delete the weapon yeah I highly
doubt it would be good at this point if
you know be interested in jet least he
directed it ooh
oh yeah and he wasn't actually in it no
no or maybe but if he directed it I'll
be pretty cool yeah yeah I mean that's
probably the way we get made to be
honest with you Mel Gibson
said I'll star and direct this yeah
that's yeah that's that bearish that's
the clearest right I might be down for
that check back in hey Danny Glover
defends the [ __ ] out of Mel Gibson I
mean I could definitely dan really
defendant I could definitely see that
maybe Mel Gibson doesn't hate black
people
oh no I can't actually after what he
said now I just thought back I was like
I mean mainly hates the Jews and then I
remember the and then I was like no I'm
only saying that Danny Glover no no no
what I'm saying is this what I'm saying
is this Danny Glover it comes from a
different group of people and so like I
can see if Mel Gibson didn't have the
voice may of the the phone calls where
he says a bunch of derogatory things
about black people specifically I could
be like well of course Danny Glover
doesn't mind as much because they he's
not part of the group then Mel Gibson is
famous for targeting however I
remembered a few of the things he said
on those phone calls and I am a little
bit like I'm surprised Danny Glover is
still his friend given some of the
things he said on this freaky photo a
pack of suggests a level of humanity
that you're not considering so I don't
know and Mel Gibson is a person for this
debate who I don't know I haven't seen
his contrition I don't know if he's
grown as a person I I don't know what
the evidence is if his [ __ ] came out and
now he would be gone he'd be gone
because dead when everyone gets called
out what's the first thing people say
now you got two sides you got what the
one side going
[ __ ] this person cancel and then the
other side is going where's the evidence
where's the proof where's the proof
there's Mel Gibson hands and super book
like a silver platter [ __ ] proof Cruz
you approve I got an hour through free
you want you want a reason not to hang
with me I got a few
why did you wonder fall if I didn't
drink from there all right but thank you
beautiful bliss tiffanie Hoffman ooh
Hannibal Buress season four
the daughter of dust Jimmy Hoffa
detective Hoffman from the soft
franchise played by Kostas Mandalore
Hannibal season four and Tango in cash
to Taegu and then you know you get in to
actually be the villain now gives Arnold
Hannibal season four I think Hannibal
season four is going to happen it's
strange how the Hannibal verse no no no
it's not that it's the fact that someone
on patreon asks about Hannibal a couple
months ago and I was like sure I mean
Olivia wanted to watch it and we checked
it out I would really have one episode
left on that show one I'm on the final
episode and then suddenly I might Jeremy
Jones is reviewing it it suddenly gets
moved to Netflix like all of these
things start happening and I was like if
people really championing for a season
for that show so I think a season four
was gonna happen for Hannibal alright
I'll watch all of it over the weekend
and we'll review it on Monday you would
love Hannibal I am told out of all the
[ __ ] that the world is pressuring you to
watch and consume Hannibal is the one
I'm I can undoubtedly be like you'll
love it you should know this about me by
now that is one of those shows that I am
just like I can't start this in case
agents of shield ends and this is the
show is because it's a popular show that
has had fans for ever since akin and on
theatre also just twelve episodes of
season unlike usual network TV Uwe Boll
yeah it's doable man would not but I'm
just watching for yourself it's too slow
of a show for that Alright reaction
that's good to know
it's like elbow reactions but I'm like
this is very it's a very deliberate man
alright chill level TV thank you for
your love TV Tehran 3 is a sequel I
would like to see ooh
well sitting in my tepee sitting in my
tepee taking a pee pee with my wee-wee
al screams kung fu' like Bruce Lee going
pee on Jet Li with hanging out Oh Mario
and Luigi while I'm squeezing my
squeegee
dude this is what you guys came up Iggy
feeds you honor brand recognition that's
how you get your hip cop okay John
typical feminine happy fourth of July
for everyone who's not in the states
right now happy quano you're celebrating
it but Ron three is a sequel you like to
see really are you sure are you sure you
want to see a trunk that you know what
yeah actually a trompe that would be
[ __ ] awesome right about now here's
the thing for me about Tron what run on
demand Oh none of the theaters what no
no video answer man I want it to be on
kwibi yeah watch on three vehicle on
three I think is it would be in a unique
position because Tron the movie the
first movie is something you could
improve upon part 2 at least has the
score going for it and the CGI so I feel
like Tron 3 Tron still has a modern-day
opus onus to live up to of really
nailing it Opie Taylor hopefully opium
truant 3 yeah like it seems like they
can still nail Tron and so I feel like a
Tron 3 could work as long as they really
nailed try you know you know what I love
about I'm so happy and ease this year I
thought she was working um so what I
love about this live stream is that it
it's very apparent that there's new
people who keep coming in and out and
new people who join and it seems like
the majority of people who join will say
iron giant
- that is the most requested seat that
is the most champion sequel in this live
stream like like Merlin the Dark Wizard
just got murdered like an Iron Giant -
I'm like we have talked so much about
its that was the last movie I was
expecting to be like oh you know what to
be a cool one that just elicits hardcore
Henry do another one I love another
hardcore Henry and the finger rated [ __ ]
under [ __ ] ready to under scene man
yeah and as long as it's in my field of
vision I would love to see a thing too
with the effects the problem
the thing is a bummer we did a show for
Fangoria back in the day and Nerdist
called blood and guts which was a
Wednesday which was Wednesday by the way
that later became Scott Ian's blood
works but we went to a DI amalgamated
dynamics incorporated who's the company
who did all the sculptures and the
practical effects for the thing prequel
and they had some beautiful beautiful
work in their display room and they said
they they basically wasted so much of it
because they went back and painted over
it all with CGI for the prequels so yeah
like a thing sequel alone just to get
some of that like I don't think it needs
it but I would be down to one you know
what I would love a c-3po and r2d2 movie
in the style of the lighthouse know in
the style of called me but why the [ __ ]
would you
why do you mean improv like that I don't
know but I'd like one of the babies to
go get it John I give you a great set in
the style of the light you do the
lighthouse and you're like wow why would
call me my case why'd you spill your
beach most basic white you spill your BS
and you know this better than I do
right to my face I don't know you're
talking about to it boy what are you
talking about well what do I know better
than you I did take him properly yes I
agree with you though I do agree oh it's
done we can't do the lighthouse [ __ ]
I haven't seen the light no but me right
to my face have you seen call me by your
name no it was on my brain
I'm sorry I love you I don't want you my
kind I respect you that's better
respect is better than love let's get
back at it again I appreciate everyone
who's taking the time out to go to
stream labs by the way next I know I
know it can feel like an inconvenience
but I appreciate like streaming labs is
better so thank you to everyone who's
gotten here but we still pretty shell to
protecting anyone who's just here
hanging out Lester appreciate it all
helps to the yeah Kyle Sackett even
though I love the Oh John you should
take this since you introduced me to
this
even though I love the Cornetto trilogy
as a whole I'd still love to see a Hot
Fuzz - uh yeah I mean of all the films I
feel like Hot Fuzz is the one you could
follow most visibly you know it's the
one you can make a trilogy out of yeah
that's the only edit of the Cornetto
trilogy and you wanted to make a trilogy
within the trilogy would be that one
yeah yeah because you know the other to
kind of conclude but you know you could
see easily Danny and and and Nick or you
could do Sean the Dead sequel but in
style like that dude now that why'd you
spill your your pint
I just spill your what what what what no
uncut gems is oh my god should be I'm
gonna cut up a beat I'm gonna catch up
2019 all right all right case K Sackett
that's different from Kyle Saget yeah
totally different person what would be
your Thank You Kyle what would be your
top pick for a STONER sequel Kevin Smith
is already doing a good job of rebooting
sequels of his work would I go with how
high - only if Redman and Method Man
returned honestly for me it's the one
that's already been said but for me the
best stoner sequel the one I the one I'd
be most intrigued to see would have to
be pineapple Express - granted James
Franco he's got a bit of a weird
reputation right now right and that's
the problem with it he's got a fucked-up
reputation he's got a similar reputation
at Chris D'Elia
delia Martino James Franco was he really
he had a creepy reputation already so
I'm just getting ready to go down but I
guess I'd still watch it all this way
for what everyone else in the world says
yeah yeah what yeah
cool number not all right okay cool as
well I'm cool I have expressed to is is
the one I think would lend itself most
although if I'm just going for for
stoner movies I like that I would love
to go back to the world so I would say
smiley face or half-baked
ooh like the Dave Chappelle and smiley
face was a movie I watched on 4/20 with
some friends and I was surprised by how
much I I it's weird like when you hear
like oh this is a STONER movie you
assume one thing but I really enjoyed
smiley face so Carter Sean with the
Planet of the Apes Shaun of the Planet
of the Apes I'll be great I'll drop coin
right now as well as on School of Rock
to the reunion tour I would be so down a
lot of con man constants undoubtedly
it's been Constantine and Sean I thought
it would be like Man of Steel - the
whole time constant you know Constantine
and Iron Giant it's almost like the ones
who people keep coming in out those two
right there era course we're back at it
again you let me down Erik like what's
[ __ ] why is this not 58 what the
[ __ ] no no please thank you I'm glad to
see you guys don't know we're just
[ __ ] with you buddy and but thank you
either way ma'am Erik Juan doesn't
matter how much I really appreciate it
thank you buddy a good Hellraiser sequel
remake and more love for night night
free there he goes again with a movie I
don't know been waiting for a sequel for
30 [ __ ] years now and I would I
really hope another Clive Barker joint
with Clive Barker literally involved
with it happens because Clive Barker has
been sick for a long time and so I think
it's harder for him to have his prolific
of an output but yeah like a true new
like Hellraiser has been cranking out
movies for a long time I actually have
spent a little time with the guy who's
made the last few which haven't been
very well received but Hellraiser of all
that time with that guy Gary Tunnicliffe
he's a good dude
yeah did you like his movies I liked
he's an effects guy so I really like his
effects I haven't seen as hellraisers
yet I just because you know that you
wouldn't like them so you're just like I
don't want it
my friend I like his movies that I don't
like it's a combination of knowing
they're not well reviewed and the
combination of me having many sequels
between these and his to catch up on
first but but generally speaking like
yeah a new Clive Barker joint or
especially like Hellraiser when I really
went back and did my 80s slasher and
horror movie education like watched all
the classics Hellraiser was the one that
lived up to the outside perspective I
have it's like when I watched the first
Nightmare on Elm Street I was like I
really like this is a great movie but I
wasn't very scared by it or when I
watched the first Friday the 13th even
more so I was like yeah I respect this I
get why it's a classic however you know
it's fine it's not great and Hellraiser
was the one that I watched it was like
this is just as unsettling and [ __ ] up
his eyes yeah
and clay Barker has that sensibility and
he also you know he hasn't unique
perspective especially when it comes to
LGBTQ sensibilities in horror so yeah
like I would love and especially on the
heels of the new hand your politics
alright I just want to go back apt in
America again
yeah Nightbreed actually a buddy of mine
re-edited the uncut version that came
out a couple years ago and and yeah like
either of those movies I think would be
prime for an update because Clive Barker
is - one of those guys who seems like he
always has an allegorical content with
his horror so yeah I'm with Jarek that's
very true which should we do club
adventure
and then go back to the appreciate you
Eric for saying that man I love Eric I
love Eric he's so hard I would also say
let's see here Kyle Club Adventure
I got your buddy don't worry I rise a
Cobb Club Adventure man i watch The
Ventures of Tintin because of this guy
rise of the guardians to criminally
underrated they should be put in jail
for now honor written that [ __ ] is
everyone who said it wasn't that great
the great showman - but really show that
the real nature of Beatty burns my
favorite movie musical Little Nemo
ventures in Slumberland to reboot dot
Tish fascinating reboot Det ish you know
greatest showmen I did really like that
movie and I thought it would be a piece
of sh like wow and actually I think a
lot of people had that response because
that movie held on at the box office for
so long after it came out great I mean
it was like oh [ __ ] Wolverine's got a
career outside of Wolverine it's not
accurate to the who pc Barnum was at all
from what I understand but it just feel
it made no good what are you talking
about he was a great guy
he didn't exploit anybody literate yeah
he was a real compassionate he's
compassionate as [ __ ] putting those
people on display for another dog cat
but yeah I agree with those I mean I
haven't seen a half of those movies but
I respect what you gotta say and rise
the Guardians - I'm surprised hasn't
been brought up more in this chat
because that's been one that a lot of
people I know for a long time have
really been wanting to see I Rises the
Guardians nothing with the holiday
figures or is that the one with the owls
okay cuz they're here cuz I get them
confused no yeah I mean what's this is
the holiday sugar ones I guess it must
be legend of the guardians off [ __ ] now
confuses isn't there a rise of the
Guardians sequel well yeah there's rise
there's something of the guardians the
owls you fools me but I think I'm right
the owl's of Ga'Hoole
the Guardians yeah the owls no not yet
oh yeah it's the Easter Bunny and it's
father Christmas and it's Jack Frost and
yeah yes the gamble del Toro one hand
that's why is that but let's see why you
did so well the movie yeah because I
know that there's an owl movie called
guardians the rise of Ga'Hoole
and there's the girls just I've hurt the
Zack Snyder al movie is underrated as as
f as well as legend of the guardians as
yeah yeah and I've also heard the rise
of the Guardians is underrated a.m. so I
feel like both of them need a sequel my
bad it's okay no I was confused I would
uh and yes I forgot to mention this
dread to dread deserves a sequel with
Karl Urban wearing the helmet and all
that's that's definitely one that
deserves a sequel Dirty Harry six you
know John Schmo down question yes which
comedic actor was in the Dirty Harry
Deadpool movie The Dirty Harry Deadpool
is debt as a Dirty Harry movie called
the Deadpool
oh you're laughing at that [ __ ] Richard
Pryor oh you don't know movies guys in
the chat which famous comic actor George
Carlin is in the Deadpool movie who's
the one that everyone loves who I don't
find particularly funny meeting a girl
Asif II he's a comedic actor come on
guys come on come on MIB 23 drum Street
yes Jim Carrey oh dude this is what
we're gonna move back over to the supers
mmm Incredible Hulk to Dredd underworld
5 a willy wonka would always [ __ ] bust
in my boss you're always busting my
balls baby you know what somebody said
earlier was casino - I'm sorry I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry
you know too much me yeah okay so what
are we at Alexandre de risco oh no hold
on we got to pull the graphic up my dude
my dude my dude my dude these are your
rules all right Alexandre Dell
let's go no you can do it you should do
a taxi driver too bus driver limo driver
every kind of car movies jackass for
South Park movie again games bully -
oops Max Payne for Shenmue for a new and
a new Midnight Club game also you guys
are awesome you're awesome awesome thank
you so much King is not awesome that
songs life but something thank you
yeah jackass for oh that would be so fun
no they should wait like ten more years
and you can with the scene they're in
their 50 names act like the level of
stunts and it would be the only movie
where you're allowed to it would be the
only movie where you're allowed to watch
people actually die on screen because I
think it's how a lot of those dudes
would want to go out like any time
Johnny Knoxville is in dire need of a
little bit of a career restore just do
it man
that'd be great notice out obviously
South Park I actually haven't played any
of the games you listed but I'm going to
chew on for them bully 2 is perfect
because in the game you get
rehabilitation and you would learn by
the end of the game to use kindness you
know they should do they should do in
ants - ants - in a bug's life - with
Woody Allen now there's a good idea
Louie CK there's a great Christian and
Bill Cosby Oh God great
woo god it's been a long time since that
louis c.k [ __ ] came out no no a special
just came out a few months ago beautiful
bliss is back red 3 red 3 with John
Malkovich
that's the one benefit will care about
yeah that's that's the 1i I want to I
wish there was like some kind of
prediction pool of like which movies
brews will is gonna care about this no
they want to do more read movies
care about anything seriously it's up to
him oh they should do a Last Action Hero
- that would be great body rot I love
your pick that was great we'll still be
able to do it Thank You bliss red three
would be a lot of fun yeah okay so I
think we're an hour and 10 behind it's
mine on the super chat we stay focused
first yes just a couple minutes John I
be we're getting to off track
my dad movies are for life one thank you
my friend
hey guys John casts a John Cazale I like
your buddy he's on her patreon here I
love a proper swan song the die-hard
constant I heard was John McClane and
Zeus samuel l.jackson I team up again
would have loved that you would you have
loved that DHS was not the die hard 5 is
not the best I think yeah if you're
actually you know what I hired five was
terrible I don't know why never I hate
that move about samuel l.jackson
returning to the die hards I feel like
you'd be down I would love that
I would actually this'll one thing that
could get me interested in a die hard
movie again Samuel Jackson is that a
sense you mean because even though like
you know die hard one is the classic I
liked Part two and three so like I would
be I think maybe two might be a better
film than three but like I really loved
their chemistry together so yeah totally
be down from the only tire movie I don't
like is five I like them all
you know I'll give you that for four is
fun but a different movie and five I I
really didn't know horror as a blast for
is a lot of fun for AC your problem
Jolliffe you know what happened with you
John is you watched all them in a row
one day I did you went to a marathon did
I watched all three die hard movies okay
there are five many years later i watch
die hard for so I was like all those
movies no and when I saw die hard before
III I could see it wasn't the first one
or three but but die hard for I was too
enjoying myself and and by the time die
like die hard for once I understood I
was like oh
he's a superhero now is he an whatever
but diehard five like nobody gave a [ __ ]
and I hate that I want to get this out
of the way Marley and Me - Marley's
revenge Marley's revenge definitely I
would actually watch a frighteners dude
let's go down to Rizzo gaming this one's
for you g take it away wawa Wes - Wow
watt West love you guys
I would pay you know what I love ticket
West Jim West desperado rough ride no
you don't gotta not know this gun and
his brother running this Buffalo Soldier
Lucas like I told you any dancer I've
seen those friends yeah I don't wanna
sleep that's right yeah you haven't seen
it in a long time but like as who two of
the humans and like wow I remember why I
enjoyed it as a kid and I think I would
still enjoy it through that lens now he
will Smith disowns that he treats it
like a son that he's not proud to have
oh there are other movies I would disown
his catalog before that Starsky and
Hutch to Judas under seal I would be
right that movie is under raised game
that's a great call Starsky and Hutch is
an underrated comedy but yes Rizzo that
is a great call beautiful bliss is back
we got Rango
- good call Kill Bill three your call
Aleta - a lot of people's call Punisher
to which I refer or we're talking a war
zone - or Travolta - and red hot I tried
hiding a yawn that's good dev an average
voice to try too hard my yawn we do a
voice try out my honor let me like try
and not move my face that people don't
see me with Rango - I think would be
really interesting I feel like of all
these you named Aleta - is the one I
absolutely want the soonest but Rango -
I think has the potential to be the best
film and I first read the screenplay
Ringo's so my impression star Murr was
driving to a gas station and it started
with Ringo Ringo driving to a Shell
station and it just popped in my head
how Johnny
when I first read the screenplay for
Rango half way through the script I
realized them
Blaine a lizard that's how he talks it's
fight and yes and I Love You Man two
would be great rookie man leaves his
wife to be gay and gene Jeter the abyss
too will be a very fun film oh I just
saw the abyss yeah that's great movie
it has James Cameron's best right there
wow we are really behind where well be
you know we're catching up 50 minutes
behind now oh great Steven esta Don
twins Thank You Steven bridesmaid say
thank you again twins
bridesmaids and Matilda sequel thoughts
yeah I actually really liked the idea of
the triplets idea with Danny DeVito
Eddie Murphy and Arnold Schwarzenegger
yeah I thought that idea was really
funny I would be down bridesmaid sequel
sure I feel like the cast could use it
I'd be more excited if I was if it
wasn't like you know they've all had
like steady careers and then Kristen
Wiig is gonna be a Wonder Woman 84 and
that might be [ __ ] amazing you know
what I would rather see than a
bridesmaids sequel as a spy sequel all
right very funny my kids five spike has
five cancel at all that's the only movie
I wanna see whether this spike is five
where you would completely disregard the
other Spy Kids movies and you do a
proper sequel The Spy Kids one yeah that
franchise deserves it yeah thanks to you
the seeker will be a lot of fun I'm Ren
do it low you know what else would be a
great sequel diary
and Frank yeah beautiful bullets back at
it again thanks for being here my friend
happy to have you here
how about sequels we don't want I'm
saying it Captain Marvel to wood Larson
ooh oh we're going into the negativity
now okay here's a sequel I don't want
the okay what's the sequel and
development that I'm like I don't know
yeah that's a great goddamn eye is there
any sequel you guys say right now on a
spot
what are sequels that you don't want
that are [ __ ] coming out goddamn what
is they're so used to being like [ __ ]
sequels to the forum like I just
accepted everything yeah I kind of write
them out of my brain pan at a certain
point I guess I kind of don't want the
Conan one that their work they don't
like it a Conan sequel yeah oh boy like
I think they wanted me like a King Conan
movie with Arnold Schwarzenegger okay
III don't know about I don't think now
is the era where that movie is gonna do
well I feel there be a bad idea it's
gonna be a really bad idea
oh I don't I mean even though like
you're talking about the die-hard one
I don't want whatever die-hard think
they're talking about making that's the
one I don't want yeah where it's like
half prequel has that I feel like that
kind of undercuts the whole point of
diehard one he's the whole specialty of
diehard one is don't do this he's never
been in a situation like it's before but
if you do a prequel and he's and he's
been in a situation like this before
yeah then it's like yeah that's stupid
anyway what are you looking at John I'm
looking at upcoming sequels to see
animations like when you try to have
dinner with someone across the table and
they're on their phone this is what it's
like talking with you yeah but but I'm
doing something on topic oh yeah
beautiful bliss you actually just named
one that in in the in the live stream
here I don't give a [ __ ] about that
Pirates of the Caribbean one with Margot
Robbie I don't I and I have no it's
nothing to do with the fact that she's a
woman really isn't alright no I like
Martin everyone who knows
me us knows that the last two dudes of
the internet to be like [ __ ] that won't
culture me no and it's not about that
with me it just sounds like yeah it just
sounds like a terrible idea
and the way how birds of prey was
received to and we loved we love and I'm
sure it'll be fine to a certain extent
and Margot Robbie is an actor so I do
adore and I feel like not everything has
to be completely central around Jack
Sparrow necessarily the the thing that
can annoy me though and and right now
this is how it reads okay this is how it
currently reads to me is it does to a
certain extent feel like pandering
diversity and sometimes to get to a
point of diversity you got to do a
little bit of pandering so you do it's
like ultimate pendulum swing it's that
way you're like okay style aback now
skip none it's not a natural way to do
diversity you know and this this thing
about I don't know just the way how
everything is sounding about it
it just does assume like I don't know
why I can actually haven't put much
thought into it other than right now
being asked about it and I don't think
it's a I don't think currently I think
it's a good idea I haven't much had time
to formally my thoughts why should i
dial back my opinion a little bit here
me me Emma sighs I might walk out of
this going you know what actually I'm
all for now what is that me-me-me's is
coming to America to which I wonder how
that's gonna go but when it when it
comes to pirates uh that news was when I
heard where I was like okay oh wait
until I see a trailer or something
because like pirates the Caribbean with
Margot Robbie I like Paris is Kirby I
like Margot Robbie and now I'm just
sitting here going I guess all I have to
expect is a pirate movie with Margot
Robbie so I don't know if I do or don't
want that I just kind of want to see
what the trailer looks like cuz I think
it could work it just doesn't it doesn't
like inspire a bunch of energy within me
related to pirates I'm just like oh
alright yeah you'll see it doesn't make
me more interested at all in it yeah it
doesn't make me more or less interest in
the French
itself and I think it's a bad call on
the end of the fact that Johnny Depp is
actually having an upswing again because
a lot of people are realizing that like
maybe they were like that I think though
my basic summation of how I would
describe what I think about the
hamburger Johnny Depp situation is that
it sounds like overall it's a the
relationship is an abusive relationship
right so that they're both emotionally
abusive to each other
because usually it's not what I need to
get murdered and it's usually not just
like one person's abusive right the
thing though that is very disconcerting
the very upsetting about it is amber her
painting herself like she is this huge
victim and it's so Johnny Depp slowly
like this monster of a person when
there's so much of it it's the support
like oh she was this whole thing and she
was very physically abusive towards it
and so with that not get it like Johnny
Depp being like viewed as this like
terrible human being got so much
attention but all the evidence to show
lately it's like people are fighting to
get that attention like more praise more
praise but more of a spotlight and this
kind of just feels like a little bit of
an insult at this point to do another
one without him because a lot of his
personal life [ __ ] affected pirates 5 in
a lot of ways and it's like no we mean
and and now that we're trying to clear
his name up I feel like he deserves a
another proper pirates because that's a
character he really does love and as
much as Johnny Depp can seem like he
phones it in and a lot of work now
that's a character that he's very much
attached to and he's used it in a lot of
ways to give a lot of love to people
like they I can even recently he did
something like stream or something like
that as Jack Sparrow so yeah I feel like
he deserves another a proper way to go
out anyway I'm which yeah that's I just
had to get that out of the way what
sequels the only want but hey lucky for
you brie Larson has a YouTube channel
now just a sudden thanks for being here
buddy and loved talking with you he's a
huge most schools's a fan the nice guys
too that was one of the first ones I
mentioned at the top of this stream
hells yeah dr - you could make a drive -
there is a book a dry I love peel and
realized drive is based on a book and I
believe there's a sequel to don't quote
me on that but I believe there's a
sequel to the book and taxi driver -
what I remember about taxi driver - is
DeNiro had an idea for taxi driver -
that he pitched a few years ago where he
starts this clown revolution talk-show
host but but the writer thought it was a
really stupid idea I want to hear a
stupid DeNiro idea I want to hear what
that was supposed to be but yeah I mean
I like all your picks generally speaking
and in the Chad chaos brought Red Hot
Chili Peppers movie I've always wanted
to see a miniseries biopic about the
Chili Peppers Kartik Sharma welcome back
to the live stream buddy this is an
interesting prospect Tarantino remaking
inception and Nolan remaking Django
Unchained well speaking of that I mean
inception - is something I'm surprised
we haven't heard more people wanting
since they did sign a multiple contract
deal if they wanted to make another
option yeah yeah they say they sign
multiple contracts jeepers
I mean I would definitely be down for I
love these kind of swap scenarios and
there's a favorite like internet joke
meme that I read some like somebody
tweeted ages ago that I've always wanted
to come true which is you have Paul WS
Anderson and Paul Thomas Anderson each
write a script and then swap them and
each one directs the other one script
and this reminds me of that and yeah
like having Tarantino making Nolan's
script and all and make a Tarantino
script would be a fascinating prospect
because unlike Paul's WS and Thomas
Anderson one of those films I think you
could assume with largely better than
the other one whereas in this case both
would be friggin interesting to say the
least
good call whose will be more interest I
think Tarantino making inception would
be more interesting than Noah making
Django yeah because Django will be like
a little more
Preetam antic and then inception will be
a crazy dialogue I would love to see you
would step into some [ __ ] up dreams
and Tarantino's but that's the thing is
I would kind of be very periodic read
the cell yeah I would be very curious to
see Tarantino tackle a full-on
fantastical dream world yeah let's see
Anissa of our stream sorry guys ooh
where do you think I got this mug from
guys Erik horsemen Thanks sorry guys
just showed up forgot the live stream
was today Oh [ __ ] hopefully I
didn't miss a lot though I missed you
guys also Greg love the shirt thanks
Anissa it's the right size really brings
out the shoulders if you got on at 6:21
you've you've been here for you know
like a solid half she's been here a
while now I've seen you talking to chat
with some folks I appreciate you being
here nice oh you sexy little devil you
heck yeah
Ethan hold girl we got it we got a stack
of aneesa's coming oh oh whoa whoa we
got oh we got a all right we got Ethan
Holgate there we go there we go Ethan
Holgate what do you say this is based on
a real thing the room to Johnny his
vampire which is something that Tommy
was so apparently actually pitched as
why hasn't he done it
I have no friggin idea it would be
perfect everyone would watch I mean but
he has to go in with the mentality of I
have to make this one great exactly yeah
let me try to do the same kind of thing
he has to go in thinking I'm gonna
actually make a great movie that way it
could be a wonderfully terrible movie
again one of my has to do that one of my
very first experiences as a semi
industry professional was was going with
Fangoria to the set of Birdemic 2 and it
literally was that kind of thing where
the producer was like this first movie
was such a phenomenon I gotta let the
director do his thing and it was the
most conflicting set I've ever been on
because I'm like
you know you're giving a guy carte
blanche to make something terrible and
you want him to do that and and am
Birdemic it was pretty bad so I guess it
worked out but uh but yeah that that's
an odd thing to get to do and yeah it
would absolutely have to be the kind of
thing where you're not shooting for so
bad it's gonna be shooting for greatness
and not hitting it
hey I pretty I'm noticing in the concert
now a couple you guys are talking about
watching us for so long really
appreciate that you guys thank you for
watching here for several years means a
hell of a lot means a hell of a lot Oh
Eric we got Eric just saying what Eric
hopping back and forth between stream
labs and super chat says hey thank you
for all you do this is the best way for
you to to communicate in the super chats
i heavily encourage a very lengthy
discussion if anyone wants to talk back
and forth do it as a super yes we won't
read them if they're your conversation
we don't want to invade your privacy
you're so funny and that one is followed
up by one from Anissa this is a sock I
love you and thank you for being my
protector buddy on behalf of Greg and
John we all need to meet up when this
stupid virus is over and aneisa sent me
the other day like a first-hand account
of like some of this shiz they're
dealing with I know she read it to me
yeah and the er's of tejas and things is
bad so uh quarantine yourselves peeps
I'm glad you two can go talk with each
other and are super chats it means a
hell of a lot it honestly embarrassed me
feel like a bit embarrassed because I'm
like okay but I appreciate it at the
same time though appreciate it and now
here is a submission from Anissa Top Gun
to a sequel that I wish they did back
then goose is room goose is revenge he
deserves revenge Top Gun keys oh my god
no big up geese top geese lobbies
reduces children yeah top geese and
they're played by by Zoey
so we had my qbj trying to get revenge
on you know the the practice mission
that killed goose the first time they're
doing Jenny died during a practice
mission I forget I forget yes Eric thank
you Eric and Nisa screen right here Eric
says definitely need to meet up Aneesa
when this is over as soon as I lose 20
Quarantine pounds I've put on Lal love
you too and of course Greg and John I'm
glad that they reminded us of their love
for us hey as well as their love for
each other
oh no yeah I want to tell you the
foreign I wanted to see your reaction as
you came down with the disease nah it's
okay I'm clean
Patrick is we got to do some like
surprise sketch one day we're we're just
doing a reaction and one of us like
sneezes in the middle of a reaction
Turtles trailer watch I thought I you
know I'll tell you this idea later yes
Eric horseman dude 20 pounds of
quarantine pounds not bad man I mean
some people have gained more but hey
dude more what is it more cushion for
the pushin more cushion for the sex
that's right okay so dude yeah don't
worry mat more cushion around that tushy
for you more that's what I'm talking
about daddy cush tush
I'm excited look at that cushion one day
Aneesa says also he needs to think you
don't have to it's okay oh I know this
is off topic but can we talk about
Vanessa Guillen the situation which was
totally messed up I'm so happy I
finished boot camp for the military
because they treat women horribly
prayers for her family it's one of the
main reasons why I don't really
feel like fully celebrating fourth of
July right now yeah it's gonna be a
weird Independence Day I'm not gonna
celebrate it just stay in here and say
I'm not [ __ ] like washing independency
oh [ __ ] you know it's gonna like chill
what like attack but the celebration
probably but the celebration of fourth
of July honestly seems like [ __ ]
bizarre to me right now especially with
the Vanessa situation yeah I mean the
vague amount of reading I've done about
that is terrible and like I'm not
well-versed enough and I've only heard
like little bits about it by hearing
something like like that's something
I'll definitely be reading up on tonight
undoubtably yeah the military is the
last place where anything like that
should be like it should nothing like
that should happen at anybody but like
especially the the the people who are
here to protect our country should do a
good job protecting their own people no
he's [ __ ] up yeah and I've made the
mistake before of like reading some very
heavy [ __ ] before doing a live stream
when I'm like has this kind of messed-up
mentality I should wait to read it's
like I'm like we're supposed to do this
one topic right now and help people get
their minds on some [ __ ] for a little
bit but no that's something I'm elated
right briefly up on otherwise I would
you know us otherwise I would talk a lot
more length about it I mean I just want
them to find justice that's all because
like this situation at least as far as
I've read they've found the remains but
the situation is developing and like you
go read about it your your heart will
break I don't need to tell you that but
didn't finish boot camp I got hurt I
appreciate everyone in the chat who has
been always been doing the hashtags for
it and speaking about it in the chat
room I've seen it throughout this whole
stream so thank you for everyone who's
been bringing it up yeah these streams
are about fun but but also the real [ __ ]
is important yeah hell yeah Christina
thumbs up thank you just thanks for
thanks for Cena thanks for the approval
and beautiful bliss before we head back
to the stream labs for real thank you
beautiful bliss for real when this whole
insanity is over it would be time to
remember
or what it feels like without all the
fear well fear is a part of life my
friend beautiful bliss you have to
remember that everything in life comes
down to either love or fear it's just
right now fear is currently amplified in
the zeitgeist in the sphere everywhere
we go yeah and I mean fear is one of the
characters in inside-out played by Bill
Hader and he's easily one of the biggest
stars of them but that's why you have to
develop a thing called courage okay the
counselor being fearless is overrated
mmm encouraged getting yourself educated
that's important that is true no I sound
like a Maki
serious that's the way to subvert thing
yeah right there is just pretend you're
not serious okay
do do we got we got case saket back in
action Jon what did I tell you about
when you do with the way your body
language is just asked me to control the
mouse just asked me to control it
because the way you do it you close
yourself off from sorry receiving you oh
please receive this is for your own
protection
I was doing you a service I know I know
you say that you act like you're this
human condom in my life thank you
okay Sackett Thank You Kyle Saget a last
stream lab for the evening
what the [ __ ] Kyle really we're not done
what the [ __ ]
first off I love all your content and
appearances elsewhere supporting other
channels the Schmo down Entertainment
Network screen junkies new rock stars
etc final sequel that I could think that
I think could be great is dread - yeah
it's rad trying to get down from the
building how do I get down from here
[ __ ] all these bad guys have showed
up on all these other floors yeah let's
take the stairs did we find out that the
last few minutes is right after mama got
shot out of the window
yeah that it's like oh wait [ __ ] he got
knocked out and was sleeping he was on
the
Moe drug now I gotta make you back yeah
I thought I was back and then you could
do a reverse raid though whereas
literally him just trying to make it at
the bottom of this building on the roof
what the fudge but I appreciate all the
support especially everywhere else man
there's a I mean I love those collabs so
thank you thank you dude
Eric you're back on your normal level
and I respect respect Eric respect
sequel or later see you cool yeah thank
you sir like you you spoil us beyond any
yeah sequel remake for dreamscape ooh
dream escape huh what did I say I about
doing controlling the mouse what do you
want and you go right back to it a
second later look at me with your body
us understand body language okay here we
go we're welcoming everyone in who much
body language yes just keep over here oh
my god you're getting some girls in this
livestream jealous with the door what's
dreamscape we got to find out we gotta
find out what dreamscape yeah we know
1984 film oh yeah I love it
oh wait a minute Eric sent me footage of
this okay Oh Oh Dennis great looks weird
he looks like it looks like [ __ ] like
face apt Capshaw Chris Plummer goddamn
that's crazy
joint alright well there you have it
eric is championing for dreamscape the
sequel all right Dennis Quaid needs it
call Holly undoubtably
and then we could get Christopher
Plummer back and he could also play max
von Sita who again yes
made that man rest in peace fantastic
actor thank you Oh heckles yeah I see
one call for Ari let go and ask me to
country I'm controlling this [ __ ] that
every episode of the
like you're like how do I do it no oh oh
you're trying to clap back I'm gonna
give you the clap let's do this job I
don't think anything yes yeah you get my
extreme posture I love it I love seeing
you in person hey sup fellas nerdy by
nature words here holdin it down what am
i noticing oh no I just like watching
you replicate my body sorry no don't be
sorry
dartz has Riley just retracted a message
so the government will be at your door
soon enough
alright okay here we go or teks sure oh
damn we're almost caught up and by
almost we'll be there in two hours
two hours and maybe I'll make it to the
bathroom ya know I'm tired and hungry
that's the Oh Greg would you like to and
highlight the comment here from Kartik
Sharma that I'm very thankful for you do
this you like literally turn your back
towards me and it just makes me feel I
was the hump furtive alright I be
comfortable my body I'm I'm insecure as
a [ __ ] I haven't touched you in
such a long time I know now I have it I
sneezed all over the shirts garbage
shower Ferris Bueller skipped school but
the school bus has a bomb goes off and
speed goes below 50 miles per hour
Ferris is to save the bus and return
home before it before his folks holy
[ __ ] that's what we should be doing is
making dual sequels pick two movies that
only had a part one or screw the sequels
in the case of speed and just make a
sequel to two movies at the same time
Keanu Reeves Matthew Broderick it would
be awesome now you could do fake [ __ ]
Matthew Broderick in that [ __ ] yeah
that's not deep fate but deh that's the
scary thing about the agent you could
actually do these sequels now I know
well you just get someone else to play
them like you get Alden Ehrenreich to
play Ferris Bueller in the sequel
affairs
whose tail he's got such a deeper voice
I don't know why has the first thing I
thought of but also I love your idea
Karthik that's a great idea
also just real quick - Hisham kaisi
identity - I don't know how it worked
but I love identity so I'm with you
Michael ak rut oh oh I'm looking at mac
shirts right now so I'm looking at men
sure excuse me guys I wanted a shop
manager Robert - sadly we lost bob
hoskins but I bet it would have been fun
I know that was the thing that I was
bringing up at the very beginning of
this room when I was Roger Rabbit was a
lot of people don't give enough credit I
think - Bob - a big ingredient to a made
Roger Rabbit work was Bob Hoskins
performance and without Bob Hoskins
there I just don't think it would be as
effective it wouldn't be the same just
same so I appreciate you saying that
Annie so liver a nice we got two
back-to-back I'll read the first one
then you read the second one okay okay
and I love your shirt job all right
Matthew who is a professor yeah high
school girls that's really appropriate
this is a South by Christianity itself
by its the camp color from Matthew who
is my man it's a great shirt from
Matthew who is a professor now at UT and
will run for governor of Texas someday
they should do a sequel the Dazed and
Confused
they have it's called everybody wants
some no but they should do which is
Matthew McConaughey's character relevant
and work perfectly right now yeah he'll
get and then the move you'll become ad
intense drama guy getting caught in
Kansas and ham just living a solitary
life learning at a tree woman with her
but thank you for this sure - nice I
love it I wore Supernatural strands
upcoming a super net like I we I rock
your shirts a rock t-shirts Rock'em
Anisa
John named all the movies your dad is
part of Opel
take a minute I can't but uh watching
the thing he was a tgh trainee on got to
do a lot of cool stuff there he did
second unit on the Lost Boys he did body
heat he did the vagrant he did he was on
outrageous fortune he was on ruthless
people he was not a night writer the TV
show oh I remember him for oh the
practice the practice practice CSI New
York he did an episode of weeds
NCIS brim soon dad worked on cop Rock
cop Rock yeah I was on an episode of
sisters when my dad was working on it
sliders he was on lighters quantum leap
yes I know you're gay wouldn't get away
with murder Grey's Anatomy did a great
yeah now he is I think on some of it
like like on the thing he was a DGA
trainee so he ended up doing a whole
bunch of different stuff he's actually a
podcast about that called below the line
a movie with a sukira
and Riley my dad makes a lot of
pornography too much my dad assistant
directing down and scheduling those
polar time anti anti porn but berated
schedule take care of the family and
porn needs a schedule people don't come
on time all right Michael act three of
the podcast is now begun Michael Mac is
back alien 3 after Ripley Hicks and Newt
and Bishop go to sleep at the end of
aliens something where they don't all
die that would be the Neil Blomkamp's
yeah that's the one we named I want the
Neil need that he did we need that [ __ ]
that's what we do when we can't when
we're passionate we become a 90s rapidly
she use went up PCP pop culture podcasts
is back in the in the arena here hey PCP
pop-culture part check out my podcast I
did with him he's a great guy from
mission
in sexy definitely want to Kill Bill Vol
three that's what I've been saying
bring back Nikki Glaser as a grownup
obviously and also bring back l driver
with the daredevil like abilities
interesting yeah I get like a blind
sensei Daryl Hannah yeah where you think
get the daughter brainy degree me think
perf that's a great that's a great one
thanks man oh man but I would want to be
mainly focus on making Bella growing up
evening ghost
did you see the Thank You evening goes
for contributing here did you see the
Greenland movie trailer which are our
Butler no we did John we were doing a
livestream with [ __ ] action right
yeah how did you do so well in this
modem we like just did that right like a
month I derived been bein in a Breyers a
bribe debate and been so good at the
Schmo down that's how I'm good to this
moment yeah that movie looks like a
blast and actually it looks better than
what I thought it would be when are we
gonna get a real rejects movie when
Gerard Butler agrees to play one of us
I'm oh reactor I'm gonna get Gerard
Butler and Jason Mewes to play us I'm a
huge Marvel DC fan I just played The
Last of Us
- I want to compete in the movie trivia
Schmoe doubt improve my knowledge
homeless mode that should be a like a
corner of accent doing like there should
be a whole YouTube channel for guys to
do impressions of people bad American
accents PCP pop-culture podcast who says
God bless you jump when I sneezed
thank you dude I've been sitting here
letting my soul drift out through my
nose and Satan corrupt my soul but now I
feel but a lot better thank and
beautiful bliss at the same thing plus
you job thank you beautiful bliss man
you imagine if we were caught up with
the super chats on time and then you
sneeze and we've got the oh how great of
a moment
right how serendipitous what's that call
right count Drago
ooh I've encounter I go does a burden
Batman Beyond interest you yes we've
talked about it extensively already in
the last two weeks
Batman force we want a Batman Beyond
movie Batman Beyond absolutely Burton is
just icing on that cake if anything I
would Tim Burton returning for a Batman
Beyond with Michael Keaton has two solid
emotions one is yeah very excited for
that prospect rizzo gaben Ryan Beatty
the thing - thank you the thing - but
Ellen is the thing also hashtag BLM
black lives matter
amen to that bowling league michigan and
amen don't make fun of the thing - you
thought I was gonna okay alright you got
it
yeah you're right snub you should be on
camera you should share your opinions
with people the thing to bow with Ellen
I love that idea
when's Ellen gonna get canceled see
everyone hates her but I don't really
know why you know can I just - she's
better than I've watched many miss mojo
WatchMojo videos about why Ellen sucks
and I can't figure I'm still like these
all seem like her just failing at
certain jokes
alright so because Rizzo gaming has
insulted my British accent yeah which is
shitty right now oh listen to a little
Russell Brand lately and he seems to
walk to do Russell Brand is very cockney
he is I love Russell Brand the new
Russell knew Russell Brand is I love
like DM I love his in so yeah I love
Russell Brand yeah yeah he's a good
example of somebody who has had a very
interesting life character
he's great Eric Horst man thank you
celebrated Juneteenth thank which I only
just learned about cuz hashtag [ __ ] my
hashtag [ __ ] Kim white [ __ ] 4th of July
let's just have Juneteenth party you if
people feel that way now I can't blame
them that's the thing you know but you
know a hashtag [ __ ] on why you do a lot
man this guy Erica and I talked a lot of
messages and he does look he's a
contributor he's not just someone who
sits on his phone doing social media he
gets actively involved in stuff he goes
out in the world and tries to help out
so he's why shoot you wouldn't know it
he's yeah you wouldn't nobody never
contribution you wouldn't know it by his
action I make up for a lot of white
guilt maybe you wouldn't know by his
actions or his beliefs but he's no
seriously though I and I mean hell yeah
man I hope that more people know about
Juneteenth next year yeah we're reaching
the end of our ability to show these on
screen but the thing too
but it has to have Kurt Russell the same
effects but only if your dad comes back
as well John then I will see it that's
the thing of what's preventing the thing
to from getting late that's the thing is
because they need their DGA training to
come back direct though everyone's like
a look we got John Carpenter on board we
got Kurt Russell on board we got Keith
David's on boy Bravo team is back as a
composer and you know Ennio Morricone
America's bar to record like a bunch of
[ __ ] we won't we don't have the first ad
Bruce Humphrey honor to be a part of
this he's too busy working ABC show
right now and we don't have a DJ a
trainee either so we'll just we just
need him to do both I love your call I
love in the chat air Morales Christ
skyscraper too but now he has no legs
that's a great call just yeah it's so
the one leg he's got a two in John
you're fixing it I'm fixing this and I
approve you to use the mouse on this one
thanks Doug I appreciate you see it's
really hard to I don't know if will be
bad I got this I'm gonna handle I'm
gonna handle some of these comments
right now all right yeah Russell Brand
is kind of
okay I'm Paddington three but winstead
of an a in the first part it's a three
what a good name okay I got one here
Anissa also says also my mom loves both
y'all and can't wait to hang out with
y'all when you come to Texas one thing
that you will hate is the weather to be
honest because josh y'all y'all are in a
desert and it's humid that's like a
ferocious you're in a desert and it's
humid I think right or is it just
bone-dry out there but you know every
time I've been to the Midwest into the
East it's been Frick friggin humid and
it's one thing we have over everyone
else is we get hot in LA but it's a
desert so we dry off to Allen's post
here but yeah and what happened both of
us can't wait fish you know with us when
we come to Texas it's just that will
hate the weather when we get there
foursome yeah I'll get a nice his mom
yeah you should
you've earned it something nice his mom
she loves us especially collar but now
that's really sweet tire mom thank you
how the the joking sex part but I fixed
this slightly in real time Eric it's
nice and then Eric than Anissa then
Eric's so humid here in Georgia I'm
dying and he's anyway on to the third
shot of ABS
[Laughter]
laughing out loud here in Georgia
my name's Eric horseman I got the one
real reject a tune this is my southern
damdai Eric Hoffman I can't wait to see
if we call mentally intellectually taken
just don't realize
you're gonna be waking up in the middle
of night dreaming about this boys
crawling up your eardrum pop-culture
podcaster so close it's [ __ ] hot
right now two big heroes it's blazing
hot yeah and it really are and summer
has only just begun
big big PCP pop-culture podcast yeah big
hero six sequel is long overdue
I can't take these goddamn photos you
know it's okay yeah I'm surprised I
haven't done a big hero six movie I only
just a few months ago it's movies
incredible yeah well people should more
people should have seen it it's a good
movie in it and it did really well and
so on [ __ ] great Rises that they
haven't done anything with it especially
because it is a marvel property it takes
like six months to make an animated
movie - especially now see she just [ __ ]
together so I can spend ten dollars
what's wrong I know Jon miss it's why
he's not a control the mouse move your
[ __ ] hand I'm sorry here Nisa you
missed two super chats from both Indies
and Eric Wow because you get so so
anxious I wish you succeed in the window
fixing this is what happens when you get
on cocaine so different I was fixin
Lewin he does have his Al Pacino thank
you let me go off on that we am Al
Pacino I saw his face though when you
did that
we need a SM more from y'all just make
one already
I would light and he said we'll get a
snr and they won't be hungry I saw ASMR
and I also saw Mimi M said that we
should do a mukbang so I feel like we
should do an ASMR mukbang I want to do
ASMR for when you're using the toilet
it's just a bathroom sound effects real
that's all that is just every every few
minutes and me going
goddammit oh oh I see it so so it's not
the the bathroom challenge here the fan
turn on it's not the bathroom like
bodily sounds it's just your experience
of being there that's good
I appreciate that yeah it's like having
somebody know where you'd expect yeah
it's like having somebody install next
to you but who's also whispering into
your ear we all want that kind of
comfort [ __ ] we would all be faster in
the public bathroom he had that it is
easier to shoot in a public bathroom
when the guy next to me is having a
really hard time yeah because then you
know you don't have to worry about what
sounds you're making I wish things were
different
all right let's see here
all right where we at John okay we're
almost done for the day guys we're
getting close
we're almost done for the day we're so
getting close to crank 3 3 goes into
production yes straight facts alright my
count Drago count Drago I would love
thank you yeah free spin off with Daniel
Craig what the [ __ ] is he talking about
a freeze you know when Daniel Craig
played mr. freeze in the Batman oh he
means like a standalone freeze movie but
with Daniel Craig yeah what am I missing
here was freeze I tried to play freeze
in something or is he talking about
or are we just talking about having a
standalone mr. freeze I mean I think
what we'd want is a standalone freeze
movie of just freezing yeah it's the
only freeze I can do it Jon I'm sending
your flow people are asking about the
check oh you want you all know if Jon
could do an impression of Arnold it's
not very good it's not fantastic but you
know I've heard enough people who could
do a good one and then everybody could
do though you know put that cookie down
so that's about the extent of any
Arnold's I can approach I know a guy
named John blanket whose last name was
hotter for
I know a guy named John who is Tom
Hanks's stand-in who does a great Swartz
inator impersonation that it's like a
real sure one day we'll hear yeah yeah
John Donoghue is his name
he's a good guy let's see here as far as
I know him I like that yeah and Michael
Mac back in here back to the future for
there's a theory that too much time
travel breaks the body down mjf I don't
want that or want to see it the first
one is my favorite movie of all time and
I just want to support again oh well
thank you dude that's a really beautiful
way to put that is a theory that too
much time travel breaks the body down
huh and just did that yeah that like
that first move is your favorite and you
just want to like be able to support
that in like an active way even though
you don't want the necessary
circumstances to get Michael J Fox yeah
yeah like yeah I feel you yeah like it's
weird because I feel like if that theory
is anything they could justify his
physical condition you know and he seems
every time I see Michael J Fox he seem
spry and he seems like you know he's got
a good attitude but I am I don't know he
does parkour now I almost made a joke
and I didn't make the joke just combined
trying to make you yes Sam for something
much worse all I was just gonna combine
the words parkour and Parkinson's but
you know but I'm not gonna you can
imagine it it's okay there's other
things to be really sensitive about
right now yeah
once you name a few are we done yeah PCP
pop-culture podcast thank you again for
your love and support John sounds like
he's doing an impression of Daniel Craig
and knives out which is essentially what
I was doing minutes ago that doughnut
hole hole
yeah that's what I was going for like a
little foghorn leghorn which is what I
feel like they know Craig was going for
in the first place how do you how does
Joel sound I can't really hear his voice
you know I can barely avoid you loved it
so much
I wish things were different I wish I
could quit you things were different
Ellie I can't really do it right now you
know I don't have it in my head
Tyler I do oh hey buck buck
Tyler Slavens is the room to the
building I appreciate that I don't know
why Johnny said thank you so much for
reminding us thank you you can you're
working your ass off right now and he
still works in an ER okay mm-hmm with
George Clooney on the show all right
she's a Gris yeah it's [ __ ] crazy
she's a grip on the new season eyes
clean it's just a real scalpels like
okay you're the original dr. McDreamy I
don't care what they say about the other
guy dragon soldier
were you like a soldier who rides a
dragon or are you a soldier that goes is
a drag yeah you know I'm chainmail big
enough for me because I'm dragging
sequel ideas there I'd love to see a
seagull the Kevin Smith dogma I like the
way you're thinking dragon I want a
dogma see pretty soon you won't have to
be a dragon soldier anymore I could be a
screenwriter it's just a temporary job
being a dragon soldier do 21 Dragon
Rider dragon screenwriter there you go
all you got to do is change the name up
a smidge Aneesa scene John you got a
reading your southern accent ah John yes
southern accent is my favorite thing
right now that's right I do declare that
uh y'all southern accent is what brings
me the life force in this film object
now bring me my mint julep before my
Ascot starts making me sweat Oh get
ready is the only voice I'll do from now
aneesa's saying also I want to sing with
y'all one day I know y'all can sing from
a lobster a long time ago that dream I
now that and second go to a guest a
guest room she meant to say go to a gas
station but she said gasps ooh gasps
let's go to the gas gas on the street
Jesus Christ Oh that'd be fun yeah we
should go to a karaoke bar together
together I'd be fun maybe a lot of fun
but dude
what would we sing together you know we
would sing rap God free bird which rest
in peace tequila that's always funny
when a guy goes up there and does
tequila because you don't have to sing
just say that's funny or when somebody
gets up into the Knights of Cydonia to
do the one part and belt their vocal
chops before spending five straight
minutes the mic while the solo takes
over the rest of the song but rest in
peace to my friend Gary because I
actually I was hoping you would get to
meet this guy because he would do rap
God at karaoke and I was hoping you guys
would get too late pass LA a week or two
ago and the [ __ ] yeah there was a lot
going on I don't know I didn't know how
to insert it just randomly into the day
I'm just gonna call you a [ __ ] Skyy
Gary was good and he did a mean rap gun
and I wish you could have done it with
him or you know kind of shared Eminem
named Gary people sometimes confuse my
name for Gary Gary but he had two R's so
it would have been Greg Gregory Gregory
you do sorry I thought you meant to toot
and Amar's at the front door end of your
name the love is appreciated Anissa Greg
can you still do that can you see this
in the chat you can't see in the chat oh
hold on let me let me do my little magic
right here for a Christmas all right
these are gonna be the last couple super
chat okay speed round of questions Greg
can you still do the splits kind of
let's see it done a bunch of southern
accents let me try this vitro records
do not add declare I'm not right in
people waiting here don't keep them
hungry for your flexibility it's
actually put my be easier to try it out
would let me with [ __ ] which means
own drags gonna try to splits right now
we've lost all the viewers alright Greg
is gonna do his split everybody you know
as best you can send them the good juju
send him the good energy you know like
make him feel at home we're just warming
up guys this is gonna blow your flippin
socks off and damn your muscle memory is
pretty decent like that looks painful
but it also looks it looks a little
beautiful but it also looks like you've
retained so much of your muscle memory I
cannot get that low at all like I can't
and I and I will someday but do your
dear thigh muscles hurt I actually just
practice kicks in the park today for
like a half hour sorry two seconds I
love so Jim Show just wrote normal
activity definitely want to see a movie
about not a lot alright so let's do you
can touch it aye-aye Capitan oh that's
how you don't get called out on Twitter
you just wait for them to say that touch
it you can touch it
that's why that's why yeah I'm not very
good at flirting with people cuz I just
wait for overt permission just Eric
horseman just a love you just I'll love
you guys and Olivia by the way I'm from
DC which might be the 51st state soon no
southern accent no I know but you live
in Georgia but okay fine fine I take it
all back I'm going to speak like Eric
Horstman with no accent yeah and by no
accent I simply mean Ohio a super face
timers on this on time yeah yeah we
should get naked
Erica they're extra sexy gotta follow
him on Instagram very sex again yeah and
anis is saying I vote for John to be the
next
next Bachelor oh thanks we got to do the
black guy first and then back to back to
why that's enough for cyber so people
still care we can do this for a year or
two but let's get back to the basics all
right let's let's get back to the status
yeah I would I don't know what it's
gonna be like I don't know if I would
want to do it but it was searching I
would love it I would love a job it's
for me you would love it I I would owe
you
he's so shy he's not confident in
muscular like the other banks man that
makes me feel alright that makes me feel
decent I'll go on it but only for you
and Nisa Rizzo Gaming says hear me out
hardcore Henry but terminator like a
Terminator movie in POV style yeah all
done down let's do it what would it be
red it would be like the Terminator
would it get annoying or would it be
Skynet puts like a cybernetic eye into
the main character and then do it like
maniac were the only like times you see
the person face on is in a mirror or
some [ __ ] like that and then there you
go
I love how Tom majors joined when I was
dredging that's funny yeah well kai do
you like that idea Ryan baby thank you I
like it too PCP pop-culture podcast
pulls an Andy Bernard and tears his
scrotum it doesn't work like the weird
thing about the splits everyone thinks
you're like splitting your crotch it's
not it's your inner thighs it's like
like when I did the splits when I was
younger people were like like always I
hurt your balls and I'm like no this is
not stretching your balls your genitalia
is contained Center legs come out from
from the joint science or understand
ball yeah cuz each of your balls stems
out of each of your thighs that's if
you're a gentleman just look at your own
balls and stand
do this to you you scratch do you do
this but if you're a guy you did that
and you're like my [ __ ] balls are in
support
yeah just crouch pay attention to what
your scrotum does and then yeah they
come back later and let me know what you
found Benares wanted to say just wanted
to say as I bring the graphic oh you did
it
just wanted to say Aneesa stay safe you
are a real hero and she is she's working
in an emergency [ __ ] brave for doing
that and what she does is super
important Thank You Aneesa yes then end
it off with Aneesa here when you all
spoke to me did I have a Texas accent no
not at all I think it was pretty
surprised by that I thought you'd be
like how you doing there guys I'm a huge
fan of the real rejects yeah no see I
thought you would come on all suave Oh
Laverne I just smoked 14 packs come on
horse when Texas toast
I love y'all's reactions Katy Orlando's
so surprisingly oh no way who said I
mean surprisingly my New York accent
barely noticeable except from I'm pissed
well but uh Katy Orlando said when you
don't have balls you definitely don't
understand la la la but I think the the
female anatomy it's the guys who rip
your vagina apart when you do splits see
what baffles me is the guys who were
saying you looked and paid attention to
what happens when you move your legs and
I also have balls because typically it's
not much okay now here's the real last
one that needs to just said I think
Sarah could see all support truly so
heartwarming because it's been hard I
bet it's been hard especially in very
understand where yeah things have not
been as I understand it as precautionary
as they could
yeah love you and he said thank you for
all the hard work you're doing
seriously ah let's put that away let's
wrap this where its opportunites go
through a couple more this is car way
off it's gonna wash out a stream really
go away off the river
Donovan Hopkins you can lasso either one
of those everyone who's contributed to
the super chats in stream labs by the
way and I'll be yeah we're gonna wrap
this up right now but and and then let's
sinan and we just saw beautiful Blissett
and he said you're a real-life hero
thank you for that a real human being
okay we how random whoa what the Vice go
now we don't need we're gonna we're
gonna put a closing the super chats
right okay well do these last two since
these guys just came in but we want to
put a closed on these and go back to the
top and get hand and then we're gonna
call this a night all right so yeah
Aneesa you are a real-life yes from
beautiful bliss that's very kind
movies are for life one which is this
John Castle can either if you cross
slash lock your legs together what do
you mean I don't know do we mean like
like you know sitting cross-legged or we
do even that thing where I mean yeah I
can do let's move the box I can yeah
cross my legs normally like this or I
can do the are you talking about the
actual like you know criss cross hey
they've turned us into monkeys on both
sides I can't do that much I can't like
lock them that way but I do you mean
well you know have you ever seen people
do that where it's like being
cross-legged except both feet are on top
of your knees that's the thing people
can do where it's like if I had what I
don't know yeah it's like you somehow
cross-legged by Erica both legs both
feet are on top of your knees or
something like that hard to do I can't
do it so I assume it must be at least a
little difficult I don't know unless I'm
totally reading your idea wrong but uh
but yeah
yeah I'm not sure but I've seen people
do it is the thing and it and it gets to
the point where your legs kind of are
locked together and I guess like Walker
I've seen people walk on their hands
with their legs that way so I don't know
I can't put my leg over my head
nah but I could do some other crazy
stretches I can do a pretty damn good
bridge I'm pretty sure I was blushing
the entire time I talk to you can't
bring this better oh yeah there you go
I'm pretty sure I was blushing the
entire time I talked to y'all and I'm
just supersonic cuz I got nervous also
jogo take my coat see I took in this as
quizzes I care more about her than you
do
that's right Aneesa I care more about
you and buildings rheumatic tension and
thank you thank you last couple super
chats by you guys thank you this is
great I love when these dreams go off
the rails this is so much fun
I'll end it with this full Lotus there
you go I think that one day we will get
more movies cool life will be great
again one day in 2023 movies will be
back in and to end this stream and it's
hard to go out now how how much higher
can you go I would say just be safe this
weekend if you are celebrating 4th of
July don't go into large groups please
be safe please be mindful consider
everyone else and yeah Deb meeting the
real rejection collab again I love dead
meat he's great Debbie took a real
liking to Olivia goddamn know because
she speaks rested yeah and and and and
you know I mean him and Cara both are
lovely and she'll Rebecca and I would
just say like I don't know Shawn we got
any last words
guys I've gone brain dead that's what's
happening so my last words I've gone a
little brain dead and I need food yeah
guys if you're in the States
take this strange holiday weekend to
reflect on what do you think the country
ought to be and what you would like to
see out of it I don't know and for the
rest of y'all in the world just have a
nice weekend it's crazy it's chaotic out
there take a little bit of time to rest
and rejuvenate because if there's
anything that's hard to do right now
it's recharge and it's absolute
paramount so love you all for being here
and yeah take some time out for yourself
this weekend even if you're not
celebrating the dubious inception of
this country I'll tell you man
cocaine either brings out the worst or
the best in you and that was a great
closing sentence cocaine's a hell of a
drug
I'm telling you it's the bad John say
goodbye to our reject nation fans in
your southern accent play real rejects I
do declare y'all have been the most
wonderful and sophisticated of audiences
this afternoon evening and good night
y'all have yourselves a wonderful
evening sip on a mint julep and remember
the real rejects love you to the end of
time love you guys thank you so much for
being here thanks for other
contributions stay safe this weekend and
stay sexy yeah this is great she's a lot
of fun
thank you guys last